thank
you
good afternoon
please
please take your seats
we'd like to get the program started
thank you
i'd like to welcome everyone to today's
symposium
entitled aging research at yale past
present and future
we have a very exciting afternoon
planned
i'm tom gill and i direct the claude d
pepper older americans independence
center at yale which is sponsoring
today's symposium
i'd like to express
my gratitude to several persons who have
worked tirelessly to plan and organize
today's activities including denisa
compra
eliza kiewick and robin bonanno in
geriatrics
carrie falvay
mary who and michael fazusa and the
dean's office
karen purt and public affairs and
communication
susanna simaji and the development
office and the entire leadership of the
pepper center
before i make my first introduction i'd
like to briefly review a few
housekeeping items
first there will be a 10-minute break
about halfway through the program at 4
30.
the restroom
is on the mezzanine level
with access either through the elevator
uh from the ground floor up or through
the back door
at the top of the room
staff members from the program on aging
will be in the aisles to assist you
if needed
second we've distributed
index cards perhaps as you were walking
into the room
as a mechanism to solicit questions for
our panel discussion which will take
place at the end of the program
if you'd like to ask a question please
jot it down
on the index card during the talks and
our staff will collect the cards at the
end of each row following the talks
if you would like to direct your
question to one of our
speakers please indicate that on the
index card
finally
for those who have cell phones if we ask
you just to put them on vibrate mode if
you wouldn't mind
so we don't disturb
our speakers
i'd now like to introduce the dean of
yale school of medicine dr robert alpern
dr alpern is a nephrologist
otherwise known as a kidney expert
before assuming his current position in
2004 dr alpern was on the faculty at
university of california san francisco
and university of texas southwestern
medical center in dallas where he served
as dean from 1998 to 2004.
dr alpern has been an outstanding dean
and leader and we are fortunate that he
was able to join us for today's
symposium dr alperin
it's a it's a real pleasure uh to be
here today
um
to share uh this celebration
when i was in dallas i one of the things
we wanted to do was to build a
geriatrics program
and we realized how difficult it was
going to be and then i realized the
easiest way to do it was to move to yale
the
so this is the claude d pepper
uh older americans independence center
uh is really uh one of the jewels of
yale university and uh
you know clearly i i think we have a
geriatrics division that's the size of
many departments at yale actually larger
than many departments at yale so the
program in aging was established in 1991
and we were designated as a pepper
center in 1992
and
tom just renewed i think for the fifth
cycle
following mary
the
nih center and we've heard that the
center programs are alive and well at
the nih so
there should be many more cycles
the the center's purpose
that was
shown to me is to enhance health
well-being and and independence of older
americans
and i think that that's really uh
speaks to what geriatrics is about
you know really understanding that it's
not just keeping people alive but
there's a lot more to life and uh to try
and keep people
uh
really healthy and able to take care of
themselves and so the the center has
been incredible and
the numbers report to me they have 50
investigators in more than 70 research
projects
and the ultimate goal is that to match
longevity with the quality of life and i
think this is going to be one of the big
forefronts for medicine in the next 50
years
because uh we're getting really good at
beating down heart disease
we're getting better and better at
cancer
and people are just going to keep living
longer and longer
i think one of the major economic
problems that this country is going to
face
is if people live to 130 can they afford
for them to stop working at 65.
and i i think it actually we are getting
to this point
where we need to stay
strong not just alive
for longer uh for for the uh for it to
all work
and so that's what this center is about
and so i do want to acknowledge the
support of the nih we're delighted that
richard hodus is here today from
the
national institute of aging
he's a yale college graduate so
he has his ties here although he did
wander up to boston for medical school
but we do appreciate their support
and as i said the funds that have come
here
have really allowed the center to
support investigators all across yale
university
the um i think there's like total
funding of 33 million dollars that have
come through the center with an estimate
that it's led to about 200 million
dollars in grant funding um and so uh i
i think it's it's an incredible success
and one of the real unique strengths of
yale university
so uh that's the end of my comments
um and now i'm i'm pleased to introduce
the next speaker
so um
when they gave me the points that i was
supposed to cover today
they uh told me that well you need to
know that what rosa delauro's going to
speak about so that you don't
say the same thing she's going to say
and i said no it's no problem because
i'm going first
so
it's my pleasure though to introduce to
you a dear friend and actually a friend
of everyone in this room because of her
support for what we all tried to do
rosa was elected to the house of
representatives in 1990 a year before
the program in aging was started
she she is the ranking member
on the labor health human services and
education appropriations committee and
she can share that with you
she serves on a subcommittee responsible
for the fda the science coalition
recognized her as the 2012 champion of
science
and rosa is a spirited relentless and
inspiring leader and advocate for
science and i can tell you
that as a dean i'm continuously on
conference calls where other deans and
people tell me you need to speak to your
congress person and tell them to support
the nih
and i always tell them that would be a
waste of time for me here because rosa
is more committed to the nih than i am
rosa please
thank you so much thank you that was
very kind to refer to me as spirited a
number of my colleagues would just say
you know
downright abrasive and aggressive is
what they would uh that what they would
say about me but i am honored so honored
to be here with all of you today you
know still i'm a towny as so many of you
know born and raised in the city of new
haven and the yale buildings are still
somewhat intimidating you know when you
uh when you when you come into him but
it's wonderful to see such a crowd here
this afternoon on such an incredibly
important topic and so many uh
distinguished uh folks uh who are here
and are going to speak with you um i
adjust to what what work that is done at
the club pepper center here is and it's
gone on for 20 years uh and it is about
saving lives it's about pushing the
frontiers of knowledge and it's about
improving the quality of life
for older americans and that is well
what you said dean it is about the
quality of life because we have figured
out how to have people live longer but
what is happening
to them
in those
those years and and how is it going what
what is what are their lives are about
and so that whatever their cognition is
that they senses that their
their life is still filled with some
meaning
uh and what what they are what they are
doing and that's critically important to
me and i'll explain that uh in in in a
moment to you uh so that the work at
yale is is complemented by the work at
15 other pepper research centers across
the country
due to a foundation and i wanted to
mention this laid by an incredible
incredible human being and that was
senator
and representative
claude pepper he served in both
capacities and i would just get into a
pattern where we als always mention the
senate first rather than the house um
but
and the senate is dysfunctional and so
is the house that's dysfunctional these
days um but in any case he was a man
really someone that uh after my own
heart and i i obviously uh i was in new
jersey doing the mondale ferraro
campaign um when uh 1984 and claude
pepper came in to do some helping out so
i never did you know i always it was an
admiration from afar of what this
this man
was was all about
as a senator he advocated for national
health care
equal pay for equal work for women
cancer and heart disease
heart disease research programs and a
minimum wage
he also co-authored the legislation that
established the national cancer
institute
the first of the many national
institutes of health
institutes at the nih in his later years
he served in the u.s house as chairman
of the select committee on aging and was
known as the quote spokesperson for the
elderly and indeed an eloquent
spokesperson for the elderly so that the
aging research centers could not have
been named for a better advocate for the
elderly and here at the yale pepper
center over one hundred thousand well
over one thousand manuscripts have been
published based on work supported by the
center over the last twenty years and
over the last ten years the center has
awarded over two hundred million dollars
in research grants and career
development awards to scientists and
scholars who are pushing at aging
research across a number of disciplines
from immunology to genetics psychology
to physical therapy cardiology to
nursing and with that in mind i would
like to acknowledge and say thank you to
the speakers who are devoting their time
this afternoon to this symposium some of
the most accomplished leaders in the
field
among them dr mary tinetti the macarthur
genius grant winner who led the founding
of the pepper center in 1992 the first
investigator to identify that older
adults at risk for falling and injury
could be identified and while dr tinetti
has all of those wonderful credentials i
would just say personally to her that
her care of my 99 year old mother uh is
at the top of that uh of that top of
that list
and my mother is not easy to care for
let me tell you and dr tinetti
would would concur in that effort
so
dr steven stripmatter
lab is conducting important work in
combating alzheimer's repairing nerves
after traumatic spinal cord injury and i
was honored to tour the lab
and see
the work that was being done
by him and by others uh and that we did
it in 2011 and again that was in a
period of time when we were experiencing
uh what was being a reduction uh in uh
and funding uh for research and we were
trying to make the case of how backward
that is um and so and we'll talk a
little bit about that as well today of
what's going on dr nicholas christakis
director of yale's human nature lab
conducted pioneering research into
health social networks has been called
one of the most influential thinkers in
the world by both time and foreign
policy dr sandy chang who's lab at yale
conducts cutting-edge research into now
i'm not a scientist so is it telomoras
huh
i don't say that
always italian whenever i look at one of
these words
so you know in any case
the protein dna complexes that caps the
chromosomes how mutations and this
binding proteins can lead to
increased risk of cancer
i'm going to use my
best baseball um
analogy here and if you're a yankee fan
you'll understand this this is
murderer's row of talent uh here uh an
expert in aging research um and to uh dr
hodis at the end at the national
institute of aging thank you thank you
thank you for the great work that's
being done there uh nia the principal
federal funding agency for aging
research here at yale and all across
america uh like nih funding in so many
other areas of research nia is driving
innovation
advances discoveries that improve the
mental and physical health of older
americans they're responsible for
leading the national research effort to
combat alzheimer's through effective
early interventions and novel drug
treatments so we say thank you to you
thank you for being here and for your
great leadership
finally i would personally like to
recognize all of the doctors the nurses
the scholars the researchers here today
you work day in and day out in labs in
clinics in nursing homes and in
hospitals to push
the edge of the envelope to push the
frontiers of knowledge to care for our
seniors and to save lives i'm in awe
i am in awe
always of what you do
so many of you know that i am a survivor
of ovarian cancer
and i was so fortunate that my cancer
was discovered
in stage one
and i went under uh i was in treatment
for several months i'm cancer free for
27 years and i am here today
because of the grace of god and
biomedical research and the great work
that you do here
i have again
so much respect for what you are able to
do to make a difference in people's
lives and i believe that all medical
research is important but the aging
research conducted and supported here at
the center is particularly vital
at this moment when we are not only
experiencing the graying of america but
more and more americans as we said are
living longer
than ever and it will be on christmas
eve that my mother will be 100 years old
and that to me is
i i i i'm trying to wrap myself around
the fact that my mother is 100 years old
in addition to which i have to plan a
party or do something to acknowledge
this effort but it's it's so incredible
um and um
and i might add that she does she is out
every day i have caregivers because i'm
in washington i've
people who come in from seven to seven
at night and then from seven to seven in
the in the morning and so forth and she
goes out uh every day and i get her hair
done every day and last night she sat
with me as had her great honor of being
inducted into the connecticut women's
hall of fame and we had the video up
there and does she get it all no
but she gets enough of it
so that
there again is some value to her own
sense of value
at whatever she can understand today and
what her life is about and according to
the administration on aging seniors make
up
about one out of every eight americans
and by 2030 that number will be one
in five
then only 17 years from now there will
be over 72 million seniors in our nation
over twice as many as in 2000
as a community
and as a country
we need to be ready for this surge in
seniors as the baby boom grows older
and oftentimes
you know my mom
she retired in her 80s from the new
haven
board of aldermen and for a number of
years after that she would she would say
to me and i hear this in senior centers
because i get to visit a lot of these
places all of the time
you know these years of after you know
retirement
the golden years presumably the golden
years where
not only with my mother but i've heard
so many other seniors describe them as
the lead years
as the lead years
because of
you know and they're mostly women
women live longer than men live sorry
guys what can i tell you but we do and
we are more in danger of being in
poverty
because
of wages
and because of a retirement security and
pensions
and because in and out of the workforce
there's not that much there in social
security
at the end of the line so the highest
demographic for people in poverty today
are women who are over the age of 65 or
70
years old so we need to be about
that quality of life which is what you
do we need the research that you in this
room undertake daily we need to improve
care we need to inform our policies
support the work that you do we have to
support the investments that make all of
this groundbreaking research that you do
possible
and this is something that i don't say
in a self-serving way i fight for every
day i am not a scientist
some of the words i can't pronounce
i'm not i am a budget appropriator
but i believe in the fundamental value
of research and where it can take us and
where it has taken us i am the senior
democrat on the subcommittee that
oversees the nia and the nih funding
and i know that the most important thing
that i can do
is to help americans live longer but to
live healthier lives is to fight for
those investments in your hard work
and as much as 85 percent of yale's
federal research portfolio is funded by
the national institutes of health
i will tell you this juncture just for a
second
that we have serious difficulty
with the appropriations process
today
where
it plays out this dysfunction that is
occurring
in washington plays out
in this committee
as dr holden knows this was a committee
where
you have the most and the broadest based
bipartisan support of any
of the committees of the federal
government
and particularly in the area of research
because we had a sense none of us are
scientists
none of us are doctors or researchers
but we have a sense
that
we had a responsibility
to appropriate resources
and not earmark them
for a specific purpose
but say here is the money
you place it
where the greatest need is
that is beginning
to unravel
in so many ways and if dr collins were
here dr francis collins the head of the
nih were here
someone who i admired deeply i will tell
you that two years ago
we on the appropriations committee all
of the various uh agencies that that
come up and are funded uh through labor
health and education and human services
come before our committee and make their
case when i served earlier on the
appropriations committee the nih used to
come up and all of the institutes were
there
they talked about their groundbreaking
research they talked about where we were
going and the interplay amongst the
institutes and how that research
overlapped uh with one another and and
in in a very positive uh
sense two years ago
the committee chairman
would not allow dr collins
to come and testify
before the appropriations committee
not only did we have all of the
institutes we used to bring them in one
at a time after that to lay out
specifically
where they were going what they were
doing and the groundbreaking efforts
that were underway they would deny
the director of the national institutes
of health
a platform to testify
before us
i asked the committee chairman he did
others did they said no what i wound up
doing
because i have such a high regard for
the nih is i invited him to my home
and i invited members of congress to
come to listen to him about what was
going on at the nih so they would have
some idea
of how important
it is for us to be supportive of this
effort
one other point to let you know is this
year
this year
because of the cuts the federal cuts as
you know as sequestration that's across
the board cuts to every department
when the labor health education human
services bill
came up to be discussed that bill never
even made it
to a
subcommittee
because
the number was so low since 2010
this subcommittee has taken
a 17 percent cut
and all of the programs that it
undertakes
the ryan budget
had billions of dollars in cuts for the
nih this bill that didn't see the light
of day though i saw a draft of the bill
had an additional
1.6 billion dollar cut to the nih
that is criminal
in my mind
that is criminal in my mind
we passed the affordable care act it was
one of my proudest moments in the
congress but equally as proud was i in
doubling the nih budget between 1998 and
2003 something we need to do again that
was done on a bipartisan basis with
people like john porter my republican
colleague ralph regular and others came
together with david obi on the
democratic side um bill natcher others
who
recognized
how valuable research
is
and you know i'm going to enlist your
help here
we were never meant to go backward in
funding for the nih we need your help
i ask for your help
please
make your voices heard you have standing
i am i'm not a scientist
not a researcher you are
your voices carry
and they can tell us they can send a
message that unfortunately myself or
some of my other colleagues cannot send
that doubling resulted in real dividends
here at yale scientists recently
developed a new way to prevent staph
infections by genetically manipulating
cells they've identified a single
molecule that impacts learning and
memory suggesting new treatments for
diseases like alzheimer's all of the
groundbreaking research i mentioned
earlier relies on nih and nia funding if
you factor in population growth and
inflation nih funding right now is over
14 below what it was in 2010 the number
of research grants is lower than it has
been since 2001. this as i said
diminishes the capability to fund
research conduct clinical trials and
develop new life-saving treatments you
know better than anyone else that
medical breakthroughs just don't happen
by some alchemy they don't they happen
because of hard work and insights of
medical researchers and the strong
support of the nih and it is support
that leads to groundbreaking discovery
if we do not support this funding we
would only recognize the tremendous
losses years down the road when the
benefits of the research is not
forthcoming it would negatively affect
the health
of every american the discovery of
fundamental knowledge about how we grow
how we age become ill made dramatically
slow so too
may the treatments for the prevention
and the treatment of disease cutting
edge treatments for cancer for heart
disease for stroke for osteoporosis
arthritis that is what medical research
gives us the gift
of good health the gift of golden years
and the gift
of life
it is a gift that i have treasured for
over a quarter century
since my cancer diagnosis
and it is a gift that every american
deserves as they grow older
so i thank you
for what you're doing here at the pepper
center you're broadening our
understanding of aging and know that i
am proud
to stand with you
and the amazing and the historic work
that you all do you help to improve the
health of all americans and research
into aging as i said is something that
we should all support and we should
rally around
i again enlist your help
take the opportunity
because you have all kinds of networks
of people
and dean alpert doesn't have to call me
do i love to talk with him
but you have people and networks all
over the country
those are folks ought to get to members
of congress
and tell them what is at risk
what is at stake
and it isn't
for people other than members because
these issues affect all of our lives we
are not immune to members of congress
for what happens
in the lives of older americans
and we too are greying and aging thank
you i know it's going to be a great
afternoon for all of you thank you so
much thank you thank you thank you
thank you congresswoman with for those
really inspiring uh words
um
i'm honored to introduce our our next
speaker dr richard hodus
uh dr hodus is director of the national
institute of aging or nia
at the national institutes of health the
nia is the principal federal funding
agency for studies of the basic clinical
epidemiologic and social aspects of
aging including the pepper center
program dr hodus has been director of
the nia since 1993
and he informed us today he's the second
long longest standing
director of an nih center
dr hodus's visit to yale represents a
coming of home of sorts
since he received his bachelor degrees
uh here in 1965
before heading up north to boston for
his medical training at a school not to
be named
dr hodus is a diplomat of the american
board of internal medicine in 1995 he
was elected as a member of the dana
alliance brain initiative in 1997. he
was elected as the fellow of the
american association for the advancement
of science in 1999 he was elected to
membership in the institute of medicine
of the national academy of sciences
as author of more than 250 research
papers he's an influential scientist in
and contributor to the field of
immunology and he's been an outstanding
and tireless leader of the nia
tomorrow dr hodus will be meeting and
interacting with many of our faculty and
trainees in several different forums
including a scientific poster session
please join me in welcoming dr hodus
back to yale
well thank you very much for the chance
to to come back home it really is a a
great privilege uh to be here and a
pleasure to be following congresswoman
delauro you know she was uh
talking about times past which evoke i
think a healthy kind of nostalgia
you can perhaps imagine from her
descriptions the times not so many years
ago when republicans democrats
bipartisan members of congress and
appropriations committee would dedicate
day after day to
have come before them the directors of
each of the nih 27 institutes and
centers a chance to talk about the work
that all of you are doing to have it
appreciated to communicate to our policy
makers the importance of what was
happening and as she's noted we don't
have those opportunities so much anymore
but we can all hope the day will come
when we can once more return to uh to
that style of communication with our
national leaders
it's a great pleasure to be here and to
introduce or open this symposium the the
the title is rather pretentious i hope i
didn't really make it up but uh
what what what what is striking as
you'll see and and in a brief
summary i'll give you of the way in
which research is supported across nia
the institute on aging and some of the
major areas of research you'll see how
closely it maps really to the
presentations you'll be hearing i'm sure
that's just a coincidence uh because it
does it does reflect as noted the
leadership in each of these major areas
of science that that you here at yale
have have played so let me talk about
the major divisions of research support
at nia the first in the division of
aging biology as you can see reflected
in in the name this is the
area of discipline that looked to
understand what the underlying molecular
cellular genetic basis is for aging as
we'll turn to is a theme i think that
crosses much of what we're doing with
the recognition that what is important
for aging really underlies issues of
health across organs tissues and
lifespan so there's a centers program
which provides infrastructure and then a
series of programs in molecular cellular
biology genetics immunology want to go
on through all of the areas of basic
science you know so well in terms of a
suggestion of the future and
opportunities in this area i would just
highlight what was a very recent event
last week held in bethesda
and it was sponsored by a general
science interest group now gerard
science is a relatively uh recent term i
think coined about
2007 give credit to the folks at the
buck institute in california and it
reflects the fact that
there is likely underlying relevance for
the aging process to many of the
conditions that accompany aging and so
by understanding the biology of aging we
in fact serve not just nia's mission but
that across all of nih all those
interested in health and well-being
this interest group presented a summit
that
was opened by francis collins then had a
series of keynote presentations that
really spanned
demographics health issues and
underlying biology
you can see the session titles here dr
dixit was one of the participants there
at inflammation but inflammation stress
epigenetics all these major areas
underlying biology
have been a part now of a genocide
interest group at nih which is now 20
nih institute strong in the commitment
of institute centers and directors
to these missions so our hope is at a
time when the budget is clearly
constrained when nia and each institute
has a great challenge in funding the
outstanding research opportunities in
each field that we can increase the
commitment and conviction that research
relevant to aging is indeed relevant to
all institutes and centers and you'll be
hearing some of this today so if if
sandy talks about telomeres and their
relationship to biology the connection
to cancer will be there and so this
theme goes i think across areas of basic
biology of aging
the division of geriatric clinical
gerontology is the division that
sponsors the more clinical aspects of
aging research and the pepper centers
the older americans independent centers
such as that here are part of the
purview of this division
uh it has interest in some areas that
are quite germane to aging as a process
such as menopause some conditions that
you'll be hearing about
such as frailty or or increasing risks
of comorbidities that are accompanying
aging but it really crosses as you'll
see here many aspects of disease
condition
over an age span and
if there is a theme that i think is
becoming more and more dominant in this
area and this is not just unable to
cross nih it's one which dr tinetti has
certainly pioneered in emphasizing that
our focus for understandable reasons on
individual conditions or diseases in
isolation is important but is failing if
it doesn't account for the fact that
multiple morbidities the existence of
multiple conditions concurrently need to
be addressed this is clearly a theme
across nih across other federal agencies
in medicare medicaid and you'll be
hearing some about that today too
certainly if we're picking one major
thrust of the programs it's going to be
supported by nia nation years to come
this is at the very top of the list
i want to note one interesting
opportunity that's emerged at a time
when
funding is quite limited the nih budget
is not going up in fact it's been
decreasing of late we're certainly
looking for opportunities to collaborate
and one agency one organization that
appeared in the last two years is the
corey the patient-centered outcomes
research institute many of you may be
aware of it it's a non-governmental
agency it's funded by a tax if you will
on on
on health care premiums
and it has a budget that is increasing
year by year
and looking for opportunities to invest
in the kind of research that will be of
interest
patient-centered outcomes being the key
to what is being pursued and uh happy to
announce the very first occasion of an
investment of funds by pcori uh in an
nih-supported clinical research study in
this case clinical trial will be in the
trial it was announced some time ago now
with applications in being reviewed uh
committing up to 30 million dollars in
support of interventions in partnership
with nih to prevent falls and injuries
associated with falls and older
americans so
i think a sense of what one of the the
top themes the first well hopefully many
such collaborations and folks in an area
that's been close to aging research and
certainly close to the work here at yale
and at the pepper center
the division of behavior and social
research uh is a third of our four
extramural divisions that spans a wide
spectrum of research from individual
sciences such as psychology through the
population sciences such as demography
and economics
it has maintained a number of centers
programs as well as studies that have
for the first time characterized at a
high level of specificity
the longitudinal consequences of aging
over time in terms of health biology but
also behavior finances and social issues
uh one theme which again i think will be
related very much to what you'll be
hearing today from
from
from the presentation that talks about
the
evolutionary conservation of social
interactions is the general theme
reflected here in the rubric we call
reversibility of early disadvantage and
the reason there's a non-human primate
monkeys in the picture here in a
division of
behavior and social research reflects an
an increased understanding in the way in
which behaviors are connected to
physical and biological properties be it
epigenetic changes in dna that reflect
the outcomes of
of experience and exposure but issues
that are common to all organisms through
evolution and reversibility here
reflects to the fact that early life
experience sometimes adverse produces
consequences which if not interfered
with themselves can be quite negative
they can now in very exciting areas of
research be understood in terms of both
behavior but also the underlying
associated biology and epigenetics and
the ability to reverse such changes
holding great promise to try to devise
interventions be they behavioral or
biological to address and reverse
outcomes in particular adverse events
that may have occurred earlier in in
life and lifespan
the division of neuroscience a major in
fact the largest of the four divisions
reflects the fact that nia is the lead
agency for research and alzheimer's
disease although it's more than
alzheimer's disease that's being studied
it's changes that occur
over time with age in cognitive function
but also in other century motor
functions and functions such as as sleep
and here i just want to outline for you
some of the changes that have occurred
in the past couple of years as a result
of a national effort that has focused
resources and attention on alzheimer's
disease and in particular
the research has included a dramatic
increase in understanding genetic
contributions to alzheimer's disease we
used to show one by one the genes that
had been associated as risk or
protective factors for alzheimer's and
now i think we can much more
productively show what is i think the
future of such research not just
individual genes and names which may not
mean much to most of us or you but the
way in which these risk factors the
genes that affect alzheimer's risk fall
into categories the one you see first
here or the greatest list of genes below
it innate immune response brain
inflammatory response uh reflects a
likelihood that with so many genes that
affect the risk of alzheimer's disease
being related to inflammation that it
may be that pathways of inflammation
affecting the brain or those targets
where we will perhaps have earliest
opportunity to intervene and have income
and similarly across lipid transport
synaptic transmission cytoskeletal we're
learning more and more about the way in
which risk factors fall into patterns
that suggest underlying processes which
we hope will identify targets that can
be validated then used for intervention
the national alzheimer's project act
was an act which uh was passed by both
houses of congress and signed by the
president uh a not so common occurrence
these days
but which uh established
a national plan to address alzheimer's
disease and one important component of
that was research
the
areas of research were translated into
priorities and a plan that it has
milestones all targeted to produce
effective interventions by 2025 a stated
goal and science it's hard to promise
and we make it clear that we're not
promising and there we don't know what
the course will be but nonetheless a a
goal which motivates all of us
uh with budgets as restricted as they
are this is one area in which nih
director uh with difficult choices to be
made was able to make additional funds
available in 2012 and 2013 to carry out
some incremental studies that would not
otherwise have been done with available
budgets and i just want to stress to you
the kinds of research and the excitement
in it that are being carried out by some
examples here uh one is an approach to
identifying novel targets in alzheimer's
you know we're very effective at
following areas of research that are
promising and are undoubtedly important
but perhaps the greatest challenge is to
force ourselves motivate ourselves to
look at areas that are not what is most
apparent and so this isn't an initiative
that really asked investigators to
respond with strategies for identifying
new potential targets in alzheimer's
disease that were not the conventional
ones and the pattern of most of these
studies is really
in the opening of a very new and i think
phenomenally interesting area of science
based on on network and systems analyses
mathematical analyses of large data sets
that really has been possible only in
the last
couple of years uh that have compared
for example gene expression patterns or
protein expression patterns or gene
sequences and hundreds of people who
either have alzheimer's disease or don't
or where tissues expressed in various
areas of the brain will have different
such patterns and from all of that to
deduce the targets that not the nodes
for what appear to be the most important
pathways in disease and i think this is
an example of basic science investor
initiated that is going to open new
opportunities in this area coupled with
uh the
effort to increase our basic
discovery science base
have been some areas to translate what
we already know as promising
opportunities into clinical trials to
prevent alzheimer's disease now
sad to say we've all been highly
disappointed with the fact that the
large clinical trials addressing
alzheimer's disease in the years through
the present have been extremely
disappointing we have not yet had great
success i think there's a conviction
well-based
that a lot of this may relate to the
fact that these studies were carried out
generally in individuals who had
advanced state of changes in the brain
manifest by disease a time at which
substantial damage has been done
probably very difficult to reverse so
you'll see in the pattern of these
studies that are being supported now an
attempt to look earlier and earlier in
the underlying course of disease before
symptoms even appear
and
techniques such as brain imaging have
been enormously successful in finding
changes that in fact predict disease
years or even decades beforehand so are
now able for the first time to address
interventions at this early stage before
largely irreparable damage may have been
done with we hope greater promise
of success and so examples of some of
the studies that are being carried out
here uh the alzheimer's prevention
initiative taking individuals who have
the apo e4 allele a strong risk factor
for alzheimer's disease but who have not
yet developed any symptoms and beginning
early to address
therapy in this case therapies that
target
beta amyloid to see if it's possible to
prevent the advance the clinical stage
of disease
similarly i mentioned the
growing body of evidence that
inflammation the immune system may be
playing a role in the ideology of
alzheimer's so stimulating the innate
immune system in fact
in this case with gmcsf a hormone a
growth factor to see if it's possible to
head off the early stages of advance
there and similarly the dominant
inherited alzheimer's network trial just
to point out there are tragic families
with alzheimer's disease determined by
specific genetic mutations
where alzheimer's develops in the 50s
40s even 30s enormous tragedies but with
a lot to teach us about the underlying
biology and with individuals who are
desperate themselves for intervention so
trials such as this will actually begin
to treat people
10 or 15 years before we know with
certainty those individuals will develop
alzheimer's disease if not treated
examples of opportunities that are
arising these last years and give us a
new hope for in fact making a difference
in this very
terrible disease
and let me just uh
end with the
slide illustrating the brain initiative
this is one that was announced with a
great deal of fanfare by the the white
house
that sets the enormously ambitious goal
of over the next decade or so trying to
understand at the level of individual
neurons in the brain
not only what each of them is doing but
how they connect with one another
audacious is the word applied i think
but it's likely to drive a new
generation of neuroscience in advance
that we hope will take us to areas of
not just understanding of underlying
biology but an opportunity to see the
targets by which we can increase the
success successful aging in in the
context of the session we'll be hearing
about today in the brain in the rest of
the body in the mind and of the quality
of life and its improvement so that as
we continue our success and extending
lifespan as you've heard expressed
already we can manage to make that
lifespan of the highest possible quality
of independence and good health
so i
leave you with this as just an
expression of the breadth of research
and aging that we think holds great
promise you'll see without coincidence
this is really typical of the
cutting-edge work being done across the
programs here at yale and i look forward
with you to sharing the experience of
hearing from the very talented leaders
in the field who will be talking over
these next hours and thank you again for
the opportunity to be back here with you
thank you dr otis for updating us as
what's happening at the national level
good afternoon everybody i'm jocelyn
lamenta news 8's medical reporter
your moderator for this symposium
now over the years i've had the
privilege of having a front row seat at
yale school of medicine
watching some of the very best
and the brightest in medical science
develop breakthrough research and
treatment
then educating you on those very
subjects
i've learned a great deal from the best
and the brightest
it hasn't been easy to interview them to
be quite honest to get the to the simple
terms to get it to the point where
people at home can understand
but it's such important information that
uh
it is challenging for me because
obviously i'm not a scientist but i have
learned a lot from them
and i love the fact that i have that
that privilege to come here and learn
from them and then pass that so very
important research information to all of
the folks at home who really need to
know what's going on here at the yale
school of medicine
we are living longer thanks to what has
evolved in medicine but that has also
led to complex issues such as coping
with multiple chronic conditions and the
increasing number of people being
diagnosed in alzheimer's disease i've
done that so many stories
on alzheimer's lately
today you will hear from leading
researchers on aging and how their work
will directly impact you
and your loved ones
and just a few housekeeping reminders
just want to remind everybody that we
gave you the index cards so that you can
jot down a question for the q a which
will
occur immediately following the last
speaker we will also have a break after
the second speaker a 10-minute break
and now it is my pleasure to introduce
to you our first presenter
dr mary tinetti is the gladys phillips
crowfoot professor of medicine and
epidemiology at yale school of medicine
and chief of the section of geriatrics
she was the first investigator to
identify that older adults at risk for
falling an injury could be identified
that falls and injuries were associated
with a range of serious adverse outcomes
and that multi-factorial risk reduction
strategies were effective as well as
cost effective
her current research focus is on
clinical decision making for older
adults
in the face of multiple health
conditions
her subject
when one person has many diseases please
welcome dr mary tinetti
thank you it is really wonderful uh to
be here and i thank you very much our
special guests
who have have been here with us and um
very happy to to be able to be with you
okay
okay
so i want to start with um who my
favorite adult is
no
it was the sidewinder this is my
favorite adult um he's my father 91 year
old um this he had just climbed up 1200
feet um that's overlooking uh lake
superior going up was great coming down
not so much
but i also want to talk tell you a story
about mrs s there's an 84 year old woman
who has multiple chronic conditions
including high blood pressure she
previously had a heart attack heart
failure many of the most common chronic
conditions that older adults face every
day she had multiple of them
she also not a typically for people of
her age with multiple chronic conditions
takes many medications coumadin and
blood thinner for her atrial
fibrillation three different blood
pressure medications that also help her
heart failure
statin for her heart two medications for
her
diabetes and an ssri for her depression
again not terribly atypical for the
millions of older adults in the united
states
so ms smith and mrs s and her doctor
we're really facing many of the same
questions that we face every day they
sat down were wondering are these
medications causing any harm we know
medications have many good effects but
we also know they have harmful effects
given the number that she's taking what
kind of harm might be happening that
we're not aware of
second of all are these medications
helping what matters most to her and
third of all the most important question
that we ultimately want to be able to
answer what is the best combination of
medications for mrs s that bro provides
her benefit without harm if at all
possible
so the title of the today was go past
present and future so i'm going to take
you way to the past to the 17th century
when i first came to yale
and it's important to bear in mind that
today's approach to disease really did
evolve in the 17th century when the
evolving technologies of that time
included
for those of you who are historians
such ground-breaking technologies
stethoscopes and microscopes where for
the very first time we're able to
understand some of the pathology
underlying the conditions that people
faced were able to relate the symptoms
and impairments that they had with these
pathologies
and as humans we'd love to create
categories so we started creating
disease categories
during the 17th century as we move from
the 17th century to the 20th century
these advances in our understanding of
the pathology were matched to our
understanding and capabilities in areas
such as surgery and pharmacology and for
those botanists in the audience will
recognize this is a fox glove on one of
the very earliest medications
digitalis and so we were able to
diagnose and treat diseases based on our
understanding of the pathology and we
evolved the model of disease approach to
health care which still dominates our
medical
establishment today and has been highly
successful and is one of the many
reasons why people are living longer
but it's also important to bear in mind
when that disease approach evolved from
the 17th to the 20th century the average
life expectancy was in the 40s as
opposed to the 80s that we we see today
um second of all almost all health
encounters were for acute injury such as
portrayed in this picture or for acute
illness for which people either
recovered or they died
there were very few people with chronic
conditions and essentially nobody who
had multiple simultaneous conditions as
we evolved that approach to disease
against has been highly successful but
it's important to bear in mind what mrs
s who reflects the patient of the 21st
century
multiple chronic conditions many many
medications and importantly as i will
tell you
very and what matters most to them
so going back to that first question are
any of her medications causing her harm
as as physicians we are taught to above
all do no harm and so two two sets of
studies that we've recently completed
here
that look at that look at that issue are
we causing harm to people like mrs s
the first study was the effect of
antihypertensive blood pressure
medications in older adults with
multiple chronic conditions we know from
a array of very well designed clinical
trials where people are randomized to
either receive the treatment or not that
older adults do have benefit from blood
pressure lowering medications
fewer strokes fewer heart attacks less
heart failure but it's also important to
bear in mind that these were healthy
older adults that almost to a study
older adults with multiple chronic
conditions who are the more typical
older adult were not included in these
trials so we don't know if those
benefits for healthy older adults are
also the same in people like mrs s
and also importantly is there is some
emerging evidence of perhaps increased
risk of fall injuries
and so what we did we studied a
representative sample of older adults
throughout the united states who are
over 65 years of old age who had
hypertension average age 80 years
two-thirds 66 percent had three or more
chronic conditions very different than
the people in the clinical trials but
very very much like the people we see in
the clinic every single day
and we
by looking at the number of of blood
pressure medications and the doses we're
able to divide people into those we
essentially had no antihypertensive
medications for a range of reasons those
that took one or two are those that took
three or more and as you can see 14
because we do a pretty good job in this
country of treating hypertension there's
only 14 percent who took no medications
55 percent about half
to
one or two and 31 percent about three
and ten who took three or more blood
blood pressure medications
and basically what we did we know that
those who take medications are different
than those that don't so accounting for
all the factors that we know of that may
make that may make people who take
medications different than those that do
or those who take more different than
those who take less accounting for all
of those factors what we found was
comparing to those people who took no
anti
uh hypertensive medications those that
took one and two had no effect no
decrease in the likelihood of having a
stroke or a heart attack in the three
years of follow-up nor those who took
three or more very different from what
we found in the clinical trials but what
we did find is that again people who
took
no
blood pressure medications adjusting for
all those factors making them look more
alike
forty percent increased risk in a
serious fall injury such as a hip
fracture or a traumatic brain injury
with one to two medications and about
almost a thirty percent increase in very
serious injuries for three or more
medications
interestingly enough there was a
decreased risk in death one of the
things we're postulating perhaps it
doesn't decrease the occurrence of a
cardiovascular event
but maybe improves the mortality for
those who have an event and it's an area
that we're still exploring
but what we do summarize is that in this
population of real older adults if you
will the larger amounts of
antihypertensive medications seem to be
associated with a decreased risk of
death but an increased risk of very very
serious injuries such as hip fractures
and head injuries and at least in our
population no effect on cardiovascular
events or perhaps only a modest decrease
compared to particularly in strokes
compared to what we see in the
randomized control trials
no single study particularly
observational studies where we didn't
randomize people tell us the whole story
and i don't want the take-home message
to be that blood pressure medications
don't work but the implications are that
we need to look further and not assume
that what we see in healthy people the
same with people with multiple chronic
conditions and it may be perhaps that
they do have different effective
treatments and we need to look at the
effect in this population it may help
cardiovascular events such as stroke or
mi
but certainly at the risk of an
increased fall injury and it really
raised for us the question is how common
is this trade-off one condition better
one condition worse in people with older
adults with the treatments that we give
them
so with the help of uh jonathan
lorgenpie who's in the audience who's
now a third year medical student when he
was a first-year medical student worked
with me on this
study of what we call therapeutic
competition and what that means is
treatment of one disease it helps
treatment of other disease it hurts in
inherently in multiple chronic
conditions and treatments we have
trade-offs that we face
we help one condition we hurt another
and we were just curious how common is
this in our population of older adults
who take multiple medications
so we went back to that large randomized
a red representative sample of older
adults throughout the united states and
looked at the 26 most commonly
recommended classes of medication for
the 14 most common chronic conditions
that older adults have and asked the
very simple question how often did a
medication for one condition potentially
harm another condition
and to identify harm we looked into the
medical literature for evidence of of
medication harm on a condition
and based on a relatively systematic
review of the literature for adverse
medications in another condition
we we found that in this representative
sample of older adults
36 percent over one in three took at
least one medication that helped one of
their conditions but to potentially hurt
another
twenty percent one out of five took two
or more
and 12 took three over one in ten people
took three medications that potentially
could have harmed one of their
conditions again we don't know that they
caused harm this was the potential
telling us we need to look further to
see how often actual harm occurs
and the implications again is in quite
common that a third of our population we
are prescribing a dis uh based on
disease guidelines that drive decision
making in health care potentially
causing harm to our people
unintentionally meaning that we probably
we need to start looking at medications
and what's what what people should be on
in a different way than currently
currently do it but it also begs the
question if it helps one condition but
hurts another
are we treating what matters most to
people so that was another set of
questions
that our group did and terry freed who
was my colleague also at the program in
aging and
in intersection um has also been a world
leader on
looking at
trying to address the question of of
helping medica using medications that
help what matters most we looked at
three different studies that addressed
this question
the first was the direct trade-off in
older adults again went back to
hypertension high blood pressure serious
fall injury two of the conditions that
mrs s has one out of three people over
the age of 65 are at risk for a serious
fall injury for a whole range of reasons
and have high blood pressure this is not
a theoretical or rare trade-off it's an
incredibly common one as you remember we
found that there was a potential
increased risk of serious fall injury
with control of blood pressure so we
went out to greater new haven area and
identified 125 people who had both fall
risk as well as high blood pressure gave
them the evidence the best evidence we
have of how much likely they are to
decrease their chance of a stroke or
heart attack with good blood pressure
control with blood pressure medications
versus the best evidence we have for the
likelihood that we were going to
increase their chance of a serious fall
injury
such as a hip fracture
and we were quite surprised to find
exactly half of the people
faced with that trade-off would say it
was more important for them to avoid the
stroke or heart attacks
um
over
they were willing to have a risk of fall
injury or the medication effects such as
dizziness or strokes to dizziness or
fatigue to avoid a stroke or heart
attack but the other half said was more
important for them to avoid
uh having a fall injury again we
expected people to really prioritize
strokes and and mi prevention but people
were 50 50 almost equally split
again implying
that older adults with multiple chronic
conditions vary in what matters most to
them we cannot as physicians identify
what we should be recommending to our
parents our patients we need to get from
them what's most important to them but
it also begs the question it's really
kind of stupid i mean would you rather
have a stroke or a hip fracture i mean
i mean you know it's a little bit of a
ridiculous question
so we went back and thought about it
again well wait a second people with
multiple chronic conditions how do we
really compare these treatments to
really answer the question have we
caused benefit or have we caused harm
so we thought about it is there
something such as universal we call
universal health outcomes are there
health outcomes that are really
meaningful to patients that really
matter to patients
that all conditions exert their effect
on so that we could use these universal
health outcomes rather than the
individual outcomes such as stroke or
heart attack and are individuals able to
prioritize when faced with that
trade-off among these universal outcomes
and if so can we use these universal
outcomes to make decisions about
benefits and harms
and so dr freed has really taken the
lead on this area and indeed by asking a
whole range of older adults
throughout new haven really we're able
to really get it down to three areas
and i suspect it's not a surprise to
anybody in this audience people want to
be as functional as possible and that
could be
those daily activities such as getting
here today social activities cognitive
activities
but the people want to be functional and
they want to be as free as symptoms as
possible such as fatigue or pain and
they want to live as long as possible
survival so essentially we can take
almost every possible health outcome and
put it into one of these three
categories so it makes it much more
simpler than trying to compare a hip
fracture versus a stroke if we can
compare function symptoms and survival
but that will only work if these chronic
conditions really do affect these
universal outcomes so that was the next
study we did again going back to that
big sample in the community we looked at
five common uh chronic conditions heart
failure chronic obstructive lung disease
osteoarthritis depression and dementia
and again ask the question if you
account for all the other factors that
affect daily functioning activities of
daily living bathing dressing shopping
using the phone using transportation if
you account for all of the other factors
and and if you account for all the
effect of all the other diseases here do
these individual five diseases affect
these outcomes and what we found is all
five of them independently and very
significantly accounted for changes in
people's ability to carry out their
daily activities we found that arthritis
lung disease depression and heart
failure all affected symptoms only
dementia did not affect symptoms which
is really what you would expect
and finally
chronic lung disease dementia depression
and heart failure all increase the
likelihood that people would die so
again what we were able to show in this
study
is that
these these chronic conditions did exert
their effect on these universal outcomes
so perhaps these are the outcomes that
we should be thinking about and deciding
whether a treatment is really effective
or not but the next question we need to
address is well then can individuals
prioritize if there really is a
trade-off if we can't have it all we all
want to be as functional as possible as
free of symptoms and live as long as
possible but what if we can't can people
prioritize so that we can make the
decisions that are going to affect what
matters most to them
so dr freda and her group asked again at
large in three different studies in the
greater new haven area asked older
adults to if you had to choose rank
order the priorities among symptoms
function and survival or death and they
were able to do this and this was the
findings at least in for greater new
haven and and this was all three of the
studies combined
difference in in each of the three
studies but 42 percent thought function
was most important
uh 32 percent thought pain and other
symptoms were most important 27
prioritized survival again people vary
in what's most important to them and we
have to figure out how to incorporate
that
into the recommendations that we make
and the research that we do
so again people do think in terms of
these universal outcomes they are able
to agree on a few outcomes they are able
to articulate their priorities and they
do vary and what matters most to them
so finally it brings us to the future
and in a group in a study that uh that
dr allure and mcavoy and i are now doing
and again a very large data set what we
call the health outcomes with
medications in the elderly study we are
basically taking
all of those most common chronic
conditions that mrs s had taking all of
the medications that she's taking and
trying to say can we identify using
these universal health outcomes can we
identify which combination
of these medications are most likely to
give her benefit in the outcome that's
most important to her and which are
least likely to give her harm
and dr allure
did this nice little
schematic for me and if anybody can
tell in the audience that what that
means
you get a gold star i certainly can but
i'll translate it for you what we are
planning to do is to identify those
outcomes of symptoms function and
survival take into account all those the
effect of all the chronic conditions
look at the effect of all the other
factors that affect
individuals health in these areas and
those all those
medications and try to identify against
singles for benefit versus harm so that
we can say you don't need to take 14
medications we are going to find for you
your own personal pill
that is the combination of medications
that are best for you
that obviously is is very very much in
the future we have a very very very long
way to go dr hodus is going to have to
give us a lot more money to uh
to get there but that is definitely
where those of us here at the pepper
center are going in terms of trying to
identify uh what works in clinical
decision making with uh chronic disease
i just want to end by thanking dr hodus
and the national incident aging had
supported all of this work i talked
about today a particular thanks to the
older adults in greater new haven who
have just been quite generous in their
times participating in all of our
studies and the wonderful
people at the program in aging some of
whom were brave enough to come for the
picture but all of those who were not as
well thank you
dr tinetti thank you your presentation
really underscores the shift to
patient-centered care and of course love
the history lesson at the very beginning
as well
our next speaker
is a proud graduate of yale college who
received his md from cornell and his phd
from rockefeller university in new york
followed by residency in pathology at
brigham and women's hospital in boston
he is now associate professor in the
department of laboratory medicine and
pathology
his research focuses on telomeres yes i
can pronounce that word
the structures at the ends of our
chromosomes that maintain the integrity
of our genetic information
using mouse models his laboratory was
the first to show
that telomere binding proteins are
required to prevent the onset of
features of premature aging in stem
cells
please welcome dr sandy chang
the topic the long and short of it
telomeres in aging and cancer
well thank you very much for that
introduction and thank you to the yale
pepper center for this invitation to
speak to this
illustrative forum
okay so i'm going to switch gears a
little bit from mary's talk i'm going to
tell you about cellular aging
so the first aspect of cellular agent i
want to tell you about is an experiment
done in the fifth in the 60s by leonard
hayflick and it was a very simply um
conceptually simple experiment but with
a profound implication
so leonard hayflick took normal human
skin cells from young
patients and just patches them in
culture so what he found was that these
cells instead of growing indefinitely
like you found in normal cancer cells
these cells actually stop dividing at a
very defined stage around 60 or 70
population doublings this is very
strange because
at the time when cancer cells are used
as a model cancer cells are immortal
they divide it indefinitely so there's
something intrinsic about normal human
fibroblasts that stop your cell division
and in fact they became senescent they
adopt a very strange phenotype
quite unlike their youthful counterparts
the cells are flat
they develop binding
bylobe nuclei and they stop dividing but
they are still metabolically active so
these senescence cells are
at the time not understood as to why
they form
so what now we know that
it is because telomeres the structures
that capture the ends of all you carry
the chromosomes uh and they're the ones
the telomere structures are the ones
that dictate the the ability of cells to
uh to divide for example telomere length
is very predictive of the replicative
history of a cell and telomeres are
actually repetitive dna sequences that
caps ends of all our chromosomes and
because telomeres are intrinsic to all
cells they
offer their divisions offer a
replicative history as to how many
cycles the cell can divide
and you can think of telomeres as the
caps
the little plastic caps at the ends of
our shoe laces
so
in a functional shoelace with the proper
capping function you can thread the
shoelaces into holes and these shoelaces
are functional that these are like the
telomeres and youthful cells
if you lose the plastic capsule and
individual laces your shoelaces become
frayed no longer functional and these
are like the telomeres of senescent
cells they're no longer functional no
longer is there a capping function and
they're called dysfunctional
so this illustrates why telomeres become
dysfunctional and the reason why is
because
telomeres are part of a linear
chromosomes and these cannot be
replicated by the dna polymerase
machinery so this is what's called the
end replication problem and because of
the failure for dna polymerase to fully
replicate linear chromosomes telomere
lines shorten and you can actually
run these out on a gel and you can see
that telomeres and mortal cells actually
decline and they become very short in
senescent cells
if you look at telomere length in human
white blood cells you can see that
telomeres actually whittle down by about
70 base pairs per year of life
and you know in a long course organism
like humans you can imagine that the
amount of telomeres that we lose could
be quite substantial something like 5
000 to 8 000 base pairs in our lifespan
so what is
um what is the mechanism to prevent
telomeres and shortening in important
cells such as our stem cells
so this is uh
the enzyme telomerase enzyme i'm sure
many of you have
heard of
the enzyme telomerase has been
usurped this is a
reverse transcriptase used by the
characteric organisms to add telomeres
the novel to the ends of eukaryotic
chromosomes
it telomeres that tta gg repetitive
sequences 12 chromosomes thereby
circumventing the n-replication problem
and we we now know that telomerase is
expressed
only in certain restricted cell types
for example our stem cells and our germ
cells have telomerase activity but our
somatic cells do not and that's why
somatic cells telomeres shorten and
undergo replicative senescence
unfortunately the level of telomerase in
our in
germ cells and our stem cells does not
appear to be enough so even though those
cells have telomerase their telomeres
still continue to shorten over time in
contrast cancer cells have robust levels
of telomerase they divide indefinitely
and they're immortal
so i should mention that the discovery
of telomeres and telomerases awarded the
nobel prize in 2009 and this work was
pioneered by dr liz blackburn with
colleagues jack schulstax and carol
greider
and the reason why i put this slide here
was because telomeres were actually
discovered at yale when dr blackburn was
a
post-doc in joe gall's lab
at the yale medical school that's where
they discovered this unique structure at
the end of the chromosomes of
tetrahymena
so this is this slide illustrates our
telomere hypothesis of aging cancer and
this
hypothesis has received a lot of
experimental confirmation from work done
in my own lab and as well as those are
mothers so what we postulate is that
telomeres shorten because of
insufficient level of telomerase
and the dysfunctional telomeres ensue
and these are actually recognized as
damaged dna so dysfunctional telomeres
activate a very potent dna damage
response
that's p53 dependent so p53 is the
guardian of the genome it's a dna it's
activated by dna damage and it's a
checkpoint
so activation of p53 actually elicits
the onset of cellular senescence and in
some cells apoptosis as well so cells
actually die
when they encounter dysfunctional
telomeres in the presence of intact p53
so this is actually a very potent
anti-cancer mechanism
we've evolved this mechanism to prevent
cells with dysfunctional telomeres from
hanging around so we try to get rid of
them by either stopping their cell
division or by killing them
unfortunately an unintended consequence
of this anti-tumor mechanism is that
stem cell populations or in highly
prolific organs
diminish their function and giving rise
to premature aging phenotypes
on the other hand
dysfunctional telomeres in the setting
of p53 mutation which is commonly
encountered in many human cancers
actually is a pro-cancer mechanism
dysfunctional telomeres in the setting
of pp3 deficiency actually drives
hemogenesis and i want to talk a little
bit about this today
so we know that cancer incidence
increases age and
in fact aging is actually
the most important cause
of human cancer
so if you look at telomere length in
human prior neoplastic lesions for
example at the doctor car sum in situ in
breast cancer telomeres are actually
very short in pre-neoplastic lesions and
this is illustrated by this diagram here
this is a ductal carcinoma in situ of
the breast you can see that nuclei are
illustrated in in blue and telomeres are
these little pink dots
so in basal epithelial cells which is
the support cells of the breast stock
you can see plenty of telomeres at these
in these cells
in contrast the neoplastic luminal
epithelial cells
have
very short telomeres because of their
increased replicative histories and
these are the cells that will give rise
to breast cancer
so this slide shows that
pre neoplastic lesions have already very
short telomeres
and very short telomeres actually
engender chromosomal instability so
chromosome anti-infusions are a common
feature of cells very very short
telomeres you can see here chromosomes
are painted blue with a stain called
dappy telomeres are these little red
dots at the end of chromosomes and these
yellow arrows points to chromosomes that
have fused end to end you can see that
the side of the diffusion there are no
telomere signals telomeres are so short
that they've already joined together
causing massive genome instability
we've actually engineered this
model in the laboratory mice
and in which we delete telomerase and
the checkpoint protein p53 together in
mouse models so what happens that these
mice get cancer readily breast cancer
skin cancer and invasive colon
carcinomas
interestingly
if you inherit short telomeres
stochastically you are also prone to
develop cancer so the cancer incidence
of patients with the shortest telomeres
is something like three folds higher
than patients with the longest telomeres
and also cancer mortality also increases
so the acquisition of short telomeres is
not a good thing in terms of cancer
biology so this can be explained in this
diagram here we think that with
increasing epithelial cell renewal
with advancing age telomeres shortened
in the absence of telomerase these
telomeres become recombinogenic they
become sticky they only got end-to-end
chromosome fusion generating what's
called dicentric chromosomes chromosomes
with two centromeres and these
structures are inherently unstable they
get post opposite pulse of the spindle
apparatus in cell division generate
chromosome breaks amplifications
deletions and for example amplifications
of oncogenes or deletions of tumor
surprises could generate a genetic
mutilate that's permissive for cancer
growth so this is what happens in
carcinoma in situ the telomeres are very
short but there's genetic rearrangement
that's already permissive for cancer
development
what human cancers do in this stage is
that they can reactivate the enzyme
telomerase so they normally do not
express telomerase at this point but
when they reactivate it they can now
become invasive cancers that they
metastasize the distance size to kill
their hosts in fact 90 of all human
cancers reactivate telomerase the other
10 utilizes a alternative lengthening of
telomeres a recombination based
mechanism to maintain the telomere
length in any any way cancers do it they
have to maintain telomere length to
become invasive
so
what i've illustrated is that we have a
telomere reserve that's usually
enough for to maintain health up to
maybe around
uh 70 or so years of age so the telomere
theory of aging also will postulate that
in case p patient of individuals inherit
mutations
in telomere length
maintenance program for example in
telomerase will have inherently shorter
telomeres and these shorter telomeres
should trigger the outside disease at an
earlier age
and now we have very reliable ways to
measure telomere length in human
populations so these are five
individuals that have illustrated here
and these are telomere length and they
look like a little gaussian distribution
and this red line shows the average
tillamo length in humans so you can see
that in this particular patient patient
number two the telomeres are very short
excuse to the left if you analyze
patient number two in more detail they
actually have a lot of telomeres that
are quite critically short many of them
under 8kb of cellular length and in fact
patient number two develop a telomere
disease we call them telomopathy now
called this dyskeratosis congenita this
character is congenital as a human
disease is a telomere disease patients
have characteristic skin phenotypes
they have extremely short telomeres
telomeres less than the first percentile
and they also develop very early bone
marrow failure sometimes as early as 30
years of age in some cases
as 12 or 13 year olds bone marrow
failure is characteristic of this
disease as well as
a very high increase in cancer incidence
for example development aml and
pulmonary fibrosis is another feature
that we see in these patients so short
telomeres in this setting develop
these whole hosts of human syndromes
that are not
that can be actually be modeled in the
laboratory mice
so in this diagram i've shown you
that if you delete a telomere binding
protein called protection of telomere
one or part one
the telomeres become critically short
and hematopodic stem cells
as illustrated by these boxes here
actually become lost over time so here's
part one knock out mice at two months of
age four months of ages six months of
age you can see that the hematopoietic
cells gradually diminish and around six
month theories the stem cells are almost
completely gone and this is coupled with
almost total bone marrow failure that we
see a good phenocopy of the disease that
we see in humans and in fact
we now know that there are many
pathways
that need to be maintained
in order to prevent the onset of this
characteristic congenital and these are
all pathways involved in telomere length
maintenance i've told you about
telomerase both the telomeric rna
component and the protein component
could be mutated to cause this
characteristic congenital as well as
components that's involved in the
maturation of this enzyme
deletion of part one as i just showed
you causes disease in mouse
and mutations in this
telomere binary protein tend to causes
the skeletal congenital in humans at a
very young age 12 year olds get bone
marrow failure we recently demonstrated
that if you perturb telomere length
replication of factors for example a
protein called ctc1 critically important
in telomere replication these mice also
get bone marrow failure very early and
eliciting a phenotype reminiscent of
this characteristics is congenital
so i've told you that short telomeres
are
could be pretty bad um in terms of uh
symptoms that it could cause so is there
any way that we could ameliorate these
short telomeres and maybe perhaps
increase telomere length
so one obvious way is to express
telomerase this is uh can be readily
done in cells if you have overexpressed
telomerase telomere length increase
and you bypass the hayflick limit so
here are cells without telomerase they
send us a population doubling of 60 as i
showed you earlier but in the setting of
telomerase over expression these cells
are now immortal and what's amazing is
that even though these cells are
immortal and replicating they do not
have any genomic instability
suggesting that
expression of telomerase may be a way in
the future
to
uh slow down the rate of telomere
schrodinger we look we already could do
this in cells and recent publications
from the dependent lab have shown that
if you over express telomerase in the
laboratory mouse
it can actually rescue many of the
stem cell functions
and increase life span
in this mouse model
so the hope is that in the future we
could prevent
the onset of or the development of
dysfunctional telomeres and the genomic
stability induced by the dysfunctional
telomeres through selective activation
or transient activation of telomerase
and maybe we can even
use this to decrease resistance to
stress and do cellular senescence
while these are the benefits of
transient telomerase therapy we also
have to be cognizant of the fact that
increased telomerase expression may not
be always be a good thing
always have to worry about that if you
increase the doubling rate of any cell
you increase the rate of dna mutations
because most of the mutations happen
during dna replication and if you
increase proliferation of pre-malignant
cells for example
pre-malignant cancer initiating cells
for example
perhaps the increase in cancer incidence
would be inevitable so the challenge in
the future is to somehow add telomerase
to
the good stem cells for example and not
trigger
onset of cancer
so in summary i've told you that some of
the inherited factors like for example
the acquisition of short telomeres or
the mutations in telomere length
maintenance pathways accelerate
telomeres running generally
dysfunctional telomeres that's acts as a
dna damage promoting agent
and depending on the status of p53
telomere dysfunction can actually
promote
the onset of temperature aging through
stem cell exhaustion
or
in the in the setting of pv3 deficiency
generate cancer
through increased genomic stability we
can now reliably diagnose your telomeres
so this is maybe one way we could
quickly
apply this to the clinic in a more
general setting to look at people
uh that comes to the hospital to look at
the telomere length so perhaps people
with very short telomeres we could help
them
uh by suggesting for example lifestyle
changes we know that environmental
toxins like reactive oxygen species
carcinogen cigarette smoking also lead
to progressive telomere insurance so
so changes in lifestyle may be
beneficial
so just want to thank members of the lab
i'm not going to list them all by name
they're illustrated here and i want to
thank my funding sources particularly
the national institute of aging and dr
hodus
for his support of my research thank you
very much
thank you dr chang i will forever
visualize a telomere as a shoelace that
was perfect
way to
illustrate that we want to take a short
break right now
and you'll hear a bell ring to signal
the start of the second part of the
program so just a short 10 minute break
thank you
just
just to ask you to
to retake your seats please
we have two more
very exciting
research talks ahead of us
thank you
we have it there for you
only for just a few minutes
just in case some folks are still
outside
we certainly have learned a lot haven't
we those of us who are not researchers
and scientists
hope you have some questions for our
question and answer period which will
begin at the very end of our last
speaker
it's now my honor to presume
that with the
to resume the program with
the saul goldman family professor of
social and natural science at yale
university
dr nicholas christakis directs the human
nature
lab and is the co-director of the
institute for network science
he's a social scientist and physician
who conducts
research on social factors that affect
health
health care and longevity
his current research focuses on health
and social networks
and especially with how ill health
disability health behavior
health care and death in one person
can influence the same phenomena in
others in a person's social network this
work involves
the application of network science and
mathematical models to understand the
dynamics of it all
please welcome dr nicholas christakis
with why humans have friends
so uh thank you so thank you very much
for that introduction
so what i'm going to be speaking about
today in the 20 minutes or so that i
have is real human social networks and
not so much the online variety but
rather the kind we humans have been
making and embedding ourselves in for
tens of thousands of years
and the structure and function of human
social networks are we think deeply
rooted in our biology and in our
evolutionary past and i also want to
make a few remarks about what we might
do with this knowledge so what if we
understand the structure and function of
human social networks what's the point
of a basic science program that seeks to
understand how and why we assemble
ourselves into these networks what can
we do with this knowledge to make a
world a better place i'm going to be
telling you about a couple of
experiments that we've been doing in our
group to explore how we might intervene
in human social networks in order to
make the world better improving public
health fostering cooperation and
increasing other desirable properties of
human populations
so um so here is what so here is what a
real social network uh looks like every
dot is a person every line connecting
them is a relationship between the two
people and each of us chooses our
friends and our co-workers and inherit
in our spouses and inherits our
relatives and each of those people to
whom we are in turn connected also has
other such individuals and in the
process of each of us exercising these
choices we assemble ourselves into this
incredibly ornate structure and we
proceed to live our lives embedded in
this structure and to me social networks
are intricate things of beauty and they
are so elaborate and so complex and so
ubiquitous in fact that one has to
wonder what purpose do they serve i mean
why do we do this we humans this is the
equivalent of ant colonies we assemble
these elaborate structures
we live our lives within these
structures and they have this particular
kind of appearance as i'm going to show
you so the questions become how do
networks form how do they work and how
do they affect us and i spent the last
10 years or so researching how and why
human beings form social networks and
how they affect our lives how they
affect our health our desires our
feelings our thoughts and our actions
and we'll briefly start with the work
that we did with obesity because it sets
the stage for illustrating a number of
other uh points so now as most of you
probably know the prevalence of obesity
has been increasing dramatically over
the last uh 10 years in our society
going from about 20 of americans being
obese to 30 percent of americans being
obese and it's common to speak about
obesity as being epidemic and it's clear
that obesity is epidemic in one meaning
of the word which is that there's more
of it than there used to be before but
we wondered whether we could find
evidence evidence for obesity being
epidemic in another meaning of the word
meaning that it's some kind of contagion
between individuals could we find
evidence for a spreading process of
weight gain within human populations and
to the extent that obesity is a product
of personal choices and voluntary
behaviors and the fact given the fact
that people are embedded in these social
networks and are influenced by the
behaviors of others around them we
thought it should be possible to find
evidence for obesity epidemics
in this image taken from one of our
first studies helped us to understand
the role of social networks in obesity
every dot is a person every line between
them represents a relationship between
two people and we make the dot size
proportional to people's body mass index
so bigger dots are bigger people and in
addition we color the dots yellow if
they're properly obese and if you look
at this image you might be able to see
clusters of yellow and red dots within
the system as if there were little
outbreaks of obesity little sort of
epidemics mini epidemics within this
this social network
but still the complexity is very high
visually speaking and in any case
several questions are raised by this
clustering such as how much clustering
is there is there more clustering than
due to chance how big are the clusters
and most interestingly what might cause
the clusters
so we borrowed some ideas from
statistical physics and we analyzed the
data in the following fashion on the
y-axis is the increase in the
probability that a person is obese given
that a social contact of theirs is obese
and on the x-axis is the degrees of
separation between the two people and
what this says on the far left purple
bar that if your friends are obese
you've got a 45 percent higher
likelihood of being obese yourself and
in the red bar if your friend's friends
are obese you've got a 25 higher
likelihood of being obese and in the
orange bar if you're at three degrees of
separation if your friends friends
friends are obese you've got a 10 higher
likelihood of being obese and it's only
when i get to your friends friends
friends friends at four degrees of
separation that there's no longer a
relationship between that person's body
size and your body size so this kind of
mathematical analysis confirms a couple
of things first there's more clustering
than due to chance if there were chance
uh assortment of obese and non-obese
individuals within the social network
that the lines here would be zero
percent across the board and second that
the radius of the clusters is to three
degrees of separation so if i knew
nothing else about you then the body
size of this person who's almost
certainly a stranger to you your
friend's friend's friend for example i
would be better than chance able to
predict your body size but this analysis
doesn't tell us what might be the cause
of these clusters and there are at least
three possibilities one possibility is a
kind of social domino effect i gain
weight it makes tom gain weight tom
gained way to get sandy gained weight
and there's a kind of spreading process
through the network uh a kind of
induction effect a second possibility is
homophily or love of like or birds of a
feather flock together maybe it's not
that my weight gain causes tom's weight
gain maybe he and i form a relationship
because we have a similar body size to
begin with and a third possibility is
that it's neither that my weight is
causing his weight nor that we form a
relationship because we have a similar
body size but rather that there is
something in the context maybe a nearby
gym that makes us both lose weight or a
nearby fast food joint that makes us
both gain weight at the same time
all three of these processes are
typically present in any social
phenomenon and the challenge is to use
correct econometric methods to
disarticulate the statistical methods to
see evidence for each of those three or
to do experiments as i'll show you in a
moment
um and so and these typically occur in
anything are your kids doing drugs
because their friends are doing drugs or
are they already drug doing kids that
are choosing other drug doing kids or is
there a local pusher that's pushing
drugs on all the kids these types of
ideas can be examined with all kinds of
phenomena and so we did a variety of
observational and experimental
approaches
to sort this out and we found evidence
for induction in the social networks we
found evidence for spread of obesity a
kind of social contagion within the
system and in the process we also
documented homophily and the role of
context in a variety of ways
now we also became interested in other
sorts of phenomena for example we became
interested in human emotions when human
beings have emotions like anger or
happiness or fear or disgust we show
them
why
why do we do that
it's not hard to construct an argument
from evolutionary biology as to why we
would experience emotions why it would
increase our fitness to be able to
experience these things but not only do
i experience these things but i show
them and not only do i show them but you
can read them and not only do you read
them but you copy them
it would seem that emotional contagion
is a very deep and fundamental aspect of
human emotional experience
and in fact this function of emotions
suggests that whatever other advantages
they offer emotions are also a primitive
form of communication
now we're accustomed to thinking about
emotional contagion as fleeting and
involving a pair of people for example a
few years ago i talked about this work
in new york city and i said you know
when you're on the subway and the person
across the car from you smiles at you
and you instinctively smile back and
they said we don't do that in new york
city
and i said well everywhere else in the
world that's normal human behavior
and in fact jane goodall when she looks
at when she studied chimpanzees she saw
the chimps when one shows a play face
which is the precursor of our smiling
another chimp will show the playface
there's something very primitive and
ancient about emotional contagion and we
also realize that emotional contagion
can be broader still for example in the
punctuated and broad expressions of
anger but we wondered whether emotions
might spread beyond pairs of people and
might they do so in a more sustained way
than riots could there be a kind of a
quiet riot could there be a kind of
below the surface emotional stampede
could we borrow the mathematics that's
used to study this type of flocking
behavior in birds and in fishes and use
it and apply to humans and see whether
humans synchronously move when it comes
to emotions or other behaviors and could
we find evidence that emotions spread
across network ties well beyond pairs in
a more sustained fashion all the time
maybe in fact emotions have a collective
existence and not just an individual
existence and so we made one of the
first network maps of i think the first
network map of human emotions with nia
support
every dot is a person lines represent
relationships the blue dots are sad
people and the yellow dots are happy
people and the green dots are in between
and if you look at this image you can
once again see clusters of sad and happy
people within the social fabric it too
goes to three degrees of separation and
similar analyses to those that we did
for obesity suggest that there's a role
of induction emotional contagion and
also of homophobia and contextual
effects you might also note that there's
a structural thing because the blue dots
are more likely to be on the edges of
the network they're more likely to be
structurally on the periphery of the
social fabric
now to get around some of the problems
with drawing conclusions from
observational data and to dig deeper
into the evolutionary significance of
networks we've also begun to do
experiments so one of the experiments we
did is we brought people into the
laboratory we gave with strangers we
randomly assigned them to groups of four
and we gave them a little bit of money
and we said if you're kind and give the
money to the your colleagues these other
strangers we will multiply that money
and everyone will be better off even
though you've paid a price
so the logical thing for any individual
to do is to defect not to be kind hope
everyone else is kind and they'll
benefit but of course if everyone does
that the whole group suffers so it's a
trade-off between individual benefit and
collective benefit
and then we would ring the bell and we
would randomly assign them new strangers
and then ring a bell and randomly assign
them new strangers and we did this for
multiple rounds and what we found was
that if eleni is kind to lucas in period
one lucas goes on to be kind into erica
in period two and erica goes on to be
kind to j in period three and jay goes
on to be kind to brecken in period four
this shows a spread of kind of pay it
forward of altruism and kindness this is
not if i am kind to you do you
reciprocate the kindness this is if i'm
kind to you do you are you then kind to
her and is she then kind to her
and one of this this result was one of
the most bizarre results out of my lab
in the last five years because what i've
just shown you is that whether jay
treats brecken kindly depends on how
eleni treats lucas even though neither
jay nor brecken ever saw eleni or lucas
how i treat you depends on how she
treats her even though we don't know
those two people
because the effects spread through the
system like a kind of social contagion
so pay it forward is real and in fact
when all the ripples are added together
it's clear that the network functions as
a kind of matching grant doubling the
return on the first person's initial
contribution to the public good
and hence using both observational and
experimental methods we and others have
provided evidence that a variety of
behaviors and phenomena spread within
networks via social contagion we've
looked at obesity smoking drinking and
drug use emotional states happiness
loneliness depression i showed you some
altruism sleep exercise purchasing
behavior and ideas and the network
structure the actual mathematical
structure of these networks is highly
relevant to other sorts of phenomena
such as the spread of germs and the
spread of information understanding the
pattern of human interactions gives us
new techniques to intervene in epidemics
to stop them cold or to forecast them in
ways that alas i don't have time to
discuss today
networks also facilitate a kind of
learning social learning that involves
learning from others rather than from
one's own experience and in fact one of
the key ideas that we've been converging
on is that networks magnify whatever
they are seated with one of the reasons
we have friends
is to create a social magnifying glass
this social magnifying glass magnifies
anything it is seated with it will
magnify fascism it will magnify ebola it
will magnify violence it will also
magnify altruism and happiness and
information it is agnostic it will
magnify anything but it must be seated
you must put something into it but then
we humans by assembling ourselves into
these networks take over or kick it off
and make it much bigger
now this work with emotions and with
cooperation which are so fundamental
has gotten and coupled with the idea
that networks may have a function got us
to thinking about the evolutionary basis
of networks themselves
and human social networks always look
strikingly similar they always look like
the images that i've been showing you so
far
but they never look like this
they never look like a regular lattice
why not i mean why didn't we evolve to
be an animal that makes networks that
naturally look like this
well the striking patterns of human
social networks their ubiquity and their
apparent purpose beg the question of
whether we evolved to have them and to
particular kind of networks in the first
place
so humans are very unusual as a species
in that we form stable long-term
non-reproductive unions to other members
of our species namely we have friends
why
why do we have friends it's not hard to
construct an argument from evolutionary
biology as to why we would have sex with
other people it's rather more difficult
to explain why we befriend other people
and yet we and very few other species
engage in this very unusual behavior
so to understand this we need to under
dissect network structure a little bit
first first of all notice that in this
type of a network every position is the
same as every other position everyone
has eight friends and every one of their
friends has eight friends and if i took
this surface and wrapped it around a
sphere or more properly a doughnut every
position would be equally central and
peripheral in the network but of course
that's not what natural networks look
like natural networks have this kind of
a structure and i want to very briefly
introduce three concepts from network
science and then make a couple of points
about evolutionary biology and talk
briefly about introductions and i think
i'll be able to finish on time so um so
look at node b b has if i keep speaking
at this velocity uh so node
node b has four friends and node d has
six friends okay b on the upper left and
d on the far right this is known as the
degree of a node and people know this
about themselves you know you have five
friends you know you have four friends i
have no friends people know how many
friends they have
now look at nodes c and d c in the
middle d on the right they both have six
friends and this might be the limit of
their understanding of where they are in
the network but we with this bird's eye
view can see that c and d are very
different and i can cultivate this
intuition in you by asking you who would
you rather be if a deadly germ was
spreading through the network c or
d uh d you want to be on the edge you
want to be so that you're not going to
get whatever's spreading now who would
you rather be if a juicy piece of gossip
were spreading through the network c
right that's known as the centrality of
a node
now nodes a and b both have four friends
uh the difference between them however
is that a's friends are friends with
each other and b's friends are not so an
ace friend this is known as transitivity
my friend's friend is my friend in a my
friend's friend is not my friend in b
and all three of these traits it turns
out are heritable so in some other work
we published also with nia support on
the far right the percent of variance
explained or the heritability is shown
and 46 of the variation and how many
friends people have can be explained by
their genes now that's not a shocker
some of us are born shy some of us are
born gregarious that people vary in
their taste for friendship is not big
news
but we also find that 47 of the
variation in people's transitivity can
also be explained by your genes this is
another very bizarre result out of my
lab the last few years what i've just
told you is that if you have tom dick
and harry in a room whether dick is
friends with harry depends not just on
dick's jeans or on harry's genes but on
tom's genes
where their dick is friends with harry
depends on the genes of some other
person how can that be
we think the reason is that people vary
in their tendency to introduce their
friends to each other some knit the
networks around them together and some
do not and even centrality is also
partially heritable
so where you are in this vast fabric of
humanity depends in part on your genes
and the fundamental reality of our
desire for particular kinds of
connection has always been with us
now if social network structure has
biological and genetic antecedents and
evolutionary significance it begs the
question of how ancient this structure
is and whether we can document it in
non-modernized settings so what we would
love to do is fly ten thousand years
back to the pleistocene and map those
networks and the claim should be they
should be the same as ours now we can't
do that but the next best thing we could
do was to go and study the hadza who are
one of the last remaining
hunter-gatherer populations on the
planet they live like we did 10 000
years ago they have no material
possessions to speak of they sleep out
under the stars they don't have
agriculture and so forth and so we uh
studied 17 hadza camps around lake ayasi
and tanzania we took maida hadsa
facebook uh we made a photographic
census of all the adult hadza there are
only a thousand of them left only 500 of
them live in the traditional way we took
this hats of facebook into the field we
asked the hadza to identify their
friends in a variety of ways and to make
the long story short hadza's social
networks look just like ours visually
and mathematically in everything we
could throw at them despite the fact
that in the intervening 10 000 years
we've invented agriculture and cities
and telecommunications we make the same
networks that they do
so network structure has an ancient
origin and it doesn't seem to have
changed
and we've begun to think about and then
i'm going to present these two
experiments and then i'll stop we've
begun to think about how to exploit
these observed properties of networks
and other fundamental observations about
network structure in order to intervene
in social systems to maximize behavior
change by exploiting a mathematical
understanding of human interactions and
of the rules under girding social
contagion and we have two kinds of ideas
one is that we can manipulate
connections between people uh changing
the structure of the network or we can
manipulate contagion and change the
flows manipulate how things flow through
the system and there's expanding science
in both areas one experiment and i'm
just going to show you experiments with
respect to social contagion here's a
recent experiment of ours manipulating
contagion we decided we were going to
map networks in developing world
villages imagine the village on the left
and the village of the right every dot
is a person and the lines represent
social relationships in the village on
the right we're going to pick six people
at random and we're going to give them
an intervention like a clean water
intervention or a vaccine intervention
or an anti-malarial bed net intervention
uh and in the village on the left in the
control village we're going to give no
one an intervention now the conventional
way of thinking about interventions of
public health is to come back and look
at the people you treated and see
whether they responded i'm not
interested in the people that i treated
i'm interested in the people i didn't
treat how did the intervention spread by
contagion from the treated to the
untreated in the treatment village on
the right compared to the control
village on the left so maybe three of
the six people responded on the right
and they recruited three of their
friends so six of them responded overall
and on the left in the control village
maybe two people responded after all
what if instead however picking people
at random i pick six central people or
use some other mathematical insights to
pick who's influential who's in a
structural position of power in the
network same villages same intervention
same number of people targeted much
bigger effect potentially now maybe
three of the six respond but they
recruit 30 of their friends so i get 33
respondents for the same amount of uh
money spent and the same kind of
intervention and we can experiment with
different algorithms different ways of
picking these individuals
so we've begun to do this in different
locations around the world i'm going to
show you one study that we're doing in
the highland villages of honduras this
is what the area looks like we map the
social networks of 32 villages
spread out in space in this region we
randomly assigned the villages to
different targeting algorithms a third
of the villages the people were five
percent of the people were picked at
random a third five percent of the most
central people were picked and a third
five percent were picked by the
kristakis lab secret sauce uh in a very
special way
and uh
and the question is could we move the
whole village can we make the whole
village do what we want the same ideas
can be applied in classrooms in the
inner city in nursing homes in hospitals
to get doctors and to prescribe or
change their behavior very same ideas
can be applied broadly and what we found
was that we could do that on the y-axis
is the mean proportion of expressing
this uh this is a multivitamin
intervention and on the x-axis is time
and what we found is at the beginning
five percent of the people had the
intervention by the end nearly eighty
percent did uh and it was the best when
we use the strategy uh in the purple
strategy and we have many other similar
results
so i'm going to stop with these two
slides
think about these two objects they are
both made of carbon and as we all
learned in high school chemistry the
difference between these two objects is
how the carbon atoms are connected take
the carbon atoms and connect them one
way you get graphite which is soft and
dark connect them another way you get
diamond which is hard and clear and
there are two key intellectual ideas
here
first these properties of softness and
darkness and hardness and clearness
aren't properties of the carbon atoms
they are properties of the collection of
carbon atoms
second which properties you get depends
on how you connect the carbon atoms to
each other connect them one way you get
one set of properties connect them a
different way you get a different set of
properties
similarly the pattern of our connections
among human beings affects the
properties of social groups it is the
ties between people that make the whole
greater than the sum of its parts and
new properties maybe even cooperation or
infection resistance or intelligence may
emerge because of the connections
because of the ties between people and
not necessarily because of the people
themselves in fact our experience of the
world depends on the actual structure of
the ties around us near and far thank
you very much
dr christakis that was amazing
learned a lot from that you also
confirmed for me what oprah winfrey has
always said that an act of kindness
really does go a long way
our next speaker is dr steven strip
matter he currently holds the vincent
codes professorship of neurology at yale
and is a founding director of the yale
cellular neuroscience neurodegeneration
and repair inter-departmental program
and is a founding director of the yale
memory disorders clinic now his work has
contributed to defining the molecular
basis for brain wiring during
development and of neural repair after
adult injury
in the aging brain as laboratory has
studied the cell surface molecular
interactions occurring in degenerative
dementias he has focused on a missing
link in the alzheimer's disease process
the amyloid beta
peptide oligomers that could lead the
way to new
drug-based treatments and we should
certainly need that
when it comes to dementia please welcome
dr strittmatter
the subject is lost in thought basis for
brain malfunction and alzheimer's
disease
well it's a pleasure to be here and to
be able to speak with you and to hear
all the previous speakers um
so um
i guess i need to
it's coming help's coming
lost in thought lost in computers
all right
thank you
excellent
so uh i'm gonna focus on alzheimer's and
uh
i think i i wanted to start just by
emphasizing the need for progress in
alzheimer's we
of course
everyone in this room has probably been
affected from a loved one somebody you
know well with alzheimer's and and it's
a disease that
that really robs us of of what we're
about our intellect
our understanding what makes us human
and uh i'm not going to
belabor that or emphasize it i'm going
to put up a few slides that emphasize
the the epidemiology of alzheimer's and
why it's a huge social issue beyond the
personal issue that we all
experience so these are some numbers and
you know numbers get kind of boring but
i think these numbers are so big that we
have to actually think about them
so something in in this country some 5
million people have alzheimer's disease
and an even larger number worldwide some
at least five times this this number of
people so 25 million
there's new cases of alzheimer's
every seven seconds so if i talk too
long more people will have alzheimer's
um i wish i could just stop talking and
it would go away if only it were that
easy
it's also an enormous um
financial burden one that that
risks bringing down our our whole health
care system these are some recent
numbers
a conservative estimate is there's 200
billion dollars spent every year in the
u.s on alzheimer's care
there's actually numbers from the
alzheimer's association that are about
twice this big 400 billion these are
huge numbers it's a massive problem
one of the reasons that this is true
sort of maybe it's unfortunate but we
actually this has been alluded to
earlier we're getting better perhaps at
taking care of other illnesses which
makes alzheimer's a bigger problem
because we're not good at
treating it and fixing it and this is
just a little schematic
showing
as a cause of death alzheimer's is
increasing over the last decade whereas
these other conditions were actually
making some progress on
and coupled with this this kind of trend
and
the the relative increase in the elderly
population and of course alzheimer's is
a disease of the elderly
this number which is already huge is
predicted to triple
um by the year 2050 in this country
so
there's huge need for progress in
alzheimer's disease and i think we all
know that these are just some numbers
which which bring it home
so
what do we do about alzheimer's today
what is therapy for alzheimer's and and
unfortunately
um we we have very few uh weapons in the
fight against alzheimer's today that we
can use in the clinical situation there
are some approved medications but they
really
provide symptomatic benefit while you're
on them it helps a bit but it really
doesn't change the course of the disease
so we really don't have this a disease
modifying something that slows down or
reverses
the disease and it's been alluded to
earlier that
it's been sort of a disappointing
last several years or decade
of attempts to develop this kind of
disease modifying
therapy have failed to meet their ends
and we still don't have this kind of
desperately needed therapy
so there there have been responses to
this and dr hodus alluded to this
earlier
one approach to this idea
why these things have failed is that
they've been used too late so when the
disease has already damaged the brain to
a point where it's hard to pull things
back
and so now there are attempts to treat
earlier and trials that the nia is
supporting are
trying to make that happen and see if
therapies that we have will work at an
earlier stage
um i think a key thing is that we need
to find new drugs new targets and test
them and
develop new therapies and i'm going to
emphasize the point this depends on
molecular understanding and tell you
about some of our experience
and i just want to make one point here
again already alluded to there is this
national plan to address alzheimer's
disease and this is important progress
and it's expanding our effort
to
make a difference to discover these
therapies
but i would point out even if under the
best sort of budgetary scenarios
we may be able to
with this plan in place
uh get to a and a research effort that's
still something like 1 1000th
of what we already spend on alzheimer's
care so i would emphasize that more
effort would be in all of our interests
it's the only way we're going to get to
these disease modifying therapies
so now i'm going to dive into
alzheimer's and tell you about
what we do know about it
approaches that we've taken to it and
where we might be able to go forward
so this idea of the amyloid hypothesis
of alzheimer's disease
has been around now for a number of
years
there are chinks in its armor it's still
probably the most prevalent idea about
how alzheimer's comes about
amyloid amyloid plaques are something
that probably
most people have heard of
this sticky substance that deposits in
the brain
the when when the brain of someone who's
died of alzheimer's is studied in the
microscope there are these plaques and
i'll show you a picture of these in a
second
the major composition of these plaques
is this single peptide called amyloid
beta and this observation decades ago
was really what led to the idea that it
may be causative in the disease process
this single peptide amyloid beta
would somehow trigger the disease
there's also evidence from
as mentioned earlier the rare families
where a single gene mutation can cause
alzheimer's that's not what most
alzheimer's is but a few families carry
a gene
one of several genes where a single
mutation can introduce
the disease
and
those mutations by and large are in the
in the pathways that produce a beta
itself
and
more recently sort of over the last five
or so year there's been a large
consortium effort
to
study the progression of alzheimer's
disease again funded in part by the
national institutes of health and uh
this kind of
study of the progression into
alzheimer's so this is progression over
time from a schematic here
if one tracks patients as they develop
dementia go from cognitively normal to
mild cognitive impairment to dementia
really the first thing that's detected
whether by pet scanning or by css spinal
tap studies
are changes in a beta so it's the first
event it proceeds perhaps by decade the
eventual progression of dementia so
there may be later things that affect
tau pathology loss of brain tissue and
eventual
dysfunction of the brain but this is
another reason to think that a trigger
very far upstream is this amyloid beta
peptide
so uh how does this actually affect the
brain so this amyloid beta peptide that
i've been talking about is what deposits
in these plaques shown here in red it
comes from a gene called amyloid
precursor
protein gets chopped up and actually
most of the things that have been tried
in the clinic recently that haven't
succeeded have tried to alter this
conversion from app to a beta
or try to pull this a beta out of the
brain
so this material um accumulates but
there's there's recently quite a bit of
data that there's several forms of this
a beta peptide when it's first made it's
simply a monomer and it floats around
and we actually all have plenty of it um
actually no different than in
alzheimer's patients really
then it can form
small clumps called oligomers and i'm
going to show you a picture of those in
a second or it can go on to develop
these huge plaques and the data suggests
that it's actually these oligomers that
make the brain sick it's not these
plaques but it's the oligomers that are
unique to alzheimer's disease
once they interact with neurons they can
impair synaptic function
this eventually leads to loss of neurons
these tangles neurofibrillary tangles in
the brain
and it's this whole constellation of
events which actually produces the
dementia
a key part of this and something that
we've focused on is
the idea that this material is outside
the nerve cell
and this sort of derangement of brain
function is happening inside of nerve
cells so how does this toxic material
trigger this bad stuff in a neuron
i'm going to give you a little better
picture of that and this actually from
the nia website
this is meant to be a cell membrane here
this app protein that i was telling you
about
releases a beta and eventually it piles
up in these plaques that just gives you
some sense of scale
and over here is the normal brain each
one of these big blobs is a nerve cell
they send out all these processes you
can think of them as wires they conduct
electricity they have synaptic
connections is called where one cell
touches another and an electrical
impulse that may travel down an axon
releases a chemical and is transmitted
to an electrical impulse in the second
cell
and what seems to be uh happening
the evidence is that this a beta
oligomer can cause a disruption a
dysfunction in these synaptic
connections so how does this happen
what is this
oligomer how does it interact with the
neuron that's what i'm going to talk
about
now
these are actually some
pictures of a beta itself in an electron
microscope that we took
that the single peptide doesn't have any
structure once it makes these oligomers
you can see these dots and then when it
makes this fibril that piles up in
plaques it looks completely different
now we don't really know in a molecular
sense how this is organized but these
are some models that have been produced
in part with experimental evidence from
david eisenberg's lab at ucla
and in this state here there's really
quite a different structure the two a
beta molecules one's pointed one way and
one's pointed another and they're
twisted in what's called a cylindrin
state the key point is that this blue
stuff is very different than this yellow
stuff and it's the blue stuff which may
be most toxic to the neurons
so we decided to look into this how does
this blue cylindrin toxic stuff interact
with neurons
so what's shown here are nerve cells in
culture
and what we did was take this this is a
beta oligomer and tag it in a way that
we could see where it binds to the
neurons
and you can see that it binds to neurons
and actually in the background here
there's other cells that it doesn't bind
to
it binds only at a certain stage of
development when they start making
synapses
the monomers don't bind so all of these
things
suggested to us that this oligomer
had a specific place on the neuron that
it would stick a lot like a lock and a
key as very specific site
and
what we decided to do was to try to
figure out where this a beta oligomer
was binding on the neuron what's the
molecule that's responsible for this
and therefore allowing the downstream
bad effects of the oligomer on neuronal
function
now this is a little bit of molecular
biology i'm just going to say a few
words about we used a method called
expression cloning so the basic idea is
we didn't know what this molecule was
but we figured we'd check every
gene that there is expressed in humans
and the way we did this was to take a
cell that doesn't bind these a beta
oligomers and then one at a time add the
genes from the brain
into different cells and ask is there
any brain gene which will create these
binding sites similar to what we see on
the neuron
and there was one that did and that's
that's the result is shown here so here
these are non-neuronal cells that don't
bind a beta so they're not dark and what
we did here was introduce this one gene
which i'm going to tell you about called
prion protein and when this protein is
in these particular cells now they'll
bind the a beta oligomer in fact this
binding event looks just like what you
see on a mature neuron that has synapses
so this single uh prion protein was the
only gene out of some 200 000 that we
screened through that allowed this kind
of binding
and it suggested to us that this would
be important in the function
so let me tell you uh just briefly what
cellular prion protein is
so you may have heard of this protein
before
because it can misfold and become
infectious in what's called mad cow
disease and in fact there's evidence
that this protein
is involved in the degeneration that
happens in this other brain disease so
we figure that's what's going on in in
alzheimer's disease
so we wanted to test whether it's really
important for the synaptic dysfunction
so we do that in a piece of hippocampus
so this is a part of the brain that we
put in a dish and we record electricity
and that's what's shown here we
stimulated one of those axons that you
saw before and then we record
the synaptic connection
and if you do this in a healthy
slice
you can record this electrical potential
and then if you stimulate it a bunch and
record the potential it's greater this
is in essence sort of a memory that
happens in this chunk of brain tissue
and what had been shown before by a
number of labs was that if you do this
in the presence of this a beta oligomer
this potential is suppressed so they
can't remember the fact they got jolted
here
and if you do this entire experiment
this effect of the a beta oligomer
in a piece of brain tissue that
genetically doesn't have prion protein
now there's no effect
so the slices are protected from the bad
effect they require
prion protein in order to have this bad
effect
another thing that happens later is that
synapses are actually lost
so this is zoomed in on one of these
pieces of a neuron in culture
and you can see each of these little
synapses and if you watch them over
several hours you can see that some of
them in the presence of a beta
go away they shrivel up they're lost
this is what we worry happens in the
alzheimer's brain
and so we did this kind of experiment in
neurons that don't have prion protein
and these synapses aren't lost instead
of
losing 10 or 15 percent of the synapses
in this time period
without prion protein the neurons don't
lose their synapses
and then we wanted to see if it was
important really for something that's a
little bit more like dementia can we
test memory now there's not any perfect
model of alzheimer's disease that we can
test in the laboratory but as mentioned
before there are these cases
of alzheimer's disease
where single genes can cause the effect
in humans and so these have been
transferred into mice and the mice get
plaques this is a piece of brain with a
bunch of those blocks and the mice get
memory loss and this is just a picture
of how we test memory
so the mice go into a big tank of water
and somewhere in the tank of water
there's a platform where they can climb
out of the water
and after they've gone in the tanks a
bunch of times they learn that the
platform is here and so a healthy mouse
when it's put in this thing will go
directly here and swim around to get out
of the water
these are the alzheimer's mice that have
they have these two genes from human
alzheimer's cases
they don't know where to go they wander
all over
if the mice have these alzheimer's genes
and have plaques but they don't have
this prion protein
now their memory is over here
it's it's improved
so
getting rid of this prion protein might
actually benefit the ill effects of a
beta oligomer
and in fact a study at nyu showed with
an antibody to prying protein that
these alzheimer's mice were
corrected in their memory
and there's a nih support now at yale to
look for drugs
um
that will block this prime protein and
achieve this kind of genetic effect and
also the drug company astrazenec is
working in that
direction with antibodies
so i told you about this a beta oligomer
binding to prion protein
in studies that i'm not going to go into
we've actually mapped out a couple of
the molecular steps
in the in the neuron right after this
happens and one of these is
after prion protein is this molecule
called m-glu r5
and then a second one is this molecule
called fin
and the reason i mention these as being
important these second steps is that
there are known compounds that interact
with each of them
so this molecule m-tep
blocks this blue protein m-glu r5
and if this is given to these same
alzheimer's mice it has a beneficial
effect so this is what's scored here
is actually multiple swims as the
animals are learning so wild-type mice
quickly learn where that hidden platform
was that is they go to the small circle
in that tank i showed you before
the alzheimer's mice when they're aged
they don't do well here so they learn
slowly and additionally to having bad
memory later but if you treat these
alzheimer's mice with this drug now they
learn just as well as healthy mice do
their time to get to that platform drops
right down
and so this is something that we can
hope to to
think about studying in humans and
they're actually here at yale it's been
developed
ligands
pet ligands that can image this
particular blue molecule in a human
brain
using positron emission tomography
and the third step in this process is
this molecule fin kinase
it's also critical for this whole
pathway and in fact here again if you
see the synapse loss in an in a neuron
that doesn't have fin it doesn't happen
so this finn kinase is actually a member
of a four or five
kinase family called the sark family
it is a tie to this
phospho tau protein and the tangles of
alzheimer's disease so it really knits
this the two major pathologies of
fibulary tangles and a beta plaques
together
but importantly there's a drug that
targets this kinase it was originally
developed for cancer
it doesn't work too well in oncology but
it's safe
and there's actually now a
yale-initiated trial to test this in
alzheimer's disease and this has been
funded
again by the national institutes of
health
so i'm going to conclude here and make a
few points
i told you about these three molecules
potential new targets to approach the
alzheimer's problem
this is certainly there's many
approaches to the problem
and i think we need to pursue multiple
lines of evidence so we can actually get
one of these disease modifying therapies
towel pathology downstream here
not only is it downstream of this
pathway once it's triggered it can
actually maintain itself and spread and
this is an active area of investigation
to try to block the ongoing tau
pathology
and as dr hodus mentioned the immune
system plays a big role in regulating
the responses to a beta to tau and the
entire synaptic dysfunction that's in
the brain
there's also a lot of evidence that
alzheimer's disease interacts in a sort
of multi-disease fashion with both
diabetes and vascular disease those are
important additional places for
interaction
and we're also making a lot of progress
in other forms of dementia which teach
us something about alzheimer's disease
the two major ones being lewy body
dementia and frontotemporal dementia
and in conclusion i think we just we
need to know a lot more about the
molecular mechanisms so that we can get
to a disease modifying therapy to stop
this this burgeoning this
tsunami of alzheimer's disease that
threatens to overwhelm
um our health care system and on a
personal level is is devastating to
those whose intellect is robbed
and i'm just going to stop there and
mention
the people in my lab who did this work
and most of this has been supported by
various organizations in the nih
thanks
thank you dr stuart mata
now uh we would love to take some
questions from the audience and if i
could have all of our four speakers join
the table your seats are there
and if we have
any of the index cards
perhaps
some of our volunteers who are
collecting the cards
very good we have some cards heading
this way
of course we'd like to invite all of you
to join us as well after the q a for a
reception right outside the atrium so we
hope you join us as well
you can meet the speakers
in a more of a one-on-one and you can
speak to them more in depth thank you
very much
oh very good
dr christakis first question is
how do you determine whether people are
happy or sad
can't be very easy i have a pensive that
i got from harry potter
um
the
uh there are a variety of uh
tools that have been developed by other
scientists psychologists that measure uh
purport to measure i think reliably
emotional states and we just use those
existing tools they're uh in that
particular study we had a
a kind of psychometric scale where
people answered a set of questions and
then they could be grouped into sad and
happy uh categories
some of the other outcomes i mentioned
are a little bit easier to measure
the altruism game you actually give
people real money and see whether they
give it to other individuals
in the hadza though one of the ways we
measured the ties is we gave people
honey honey sticks which the hadza love
and we told them that you cannot keep
this for yourself you must give it
anonymously to other members of your
group
and saw what they did so we have
different kinds of objective and
subjective measures
for dr tenetti
did you ask the patients their
preferences for maintaining function
minimizing symptoms and prolonging life
more than once
and if so were their
preferences
stable
that's a that's an excellent question
and much of that work actually was uh dr
freed who i think had to leave and the
end the answer that is yes um uh
as as people change in their health
trajectories uh very often their
preferences do change over time um
so so i think one of one of the things
that she's attempting to do are there
particular
traits that do maintain so in general do
people focus on one thing rather than
another but there are also certain kind
of states that of preference that will
change as people's condition change and
it's that's really been shown very much
particularly function is young and
healthy people think if i can't run a
marathon it's not worth living right
and um and certainly as people become
more and more ill and more and more
functional what are less and less
functional what's important to them does
change and so and that is really
certainly one of the challenges if we're
going to use this in decision making is
that is that as preferences change
certainly decision making needs to
change and that that certainly is a
level of complexity that we still need
to deal with
very good
and dr
matter
question i have read that only two
activities can slow down alzheimer's one
exercise the other one is meditation can
you comment on that
um
there may be many many activities that
could slow down alzheimer's i guess the
question is which ones have been proven
in a
scientifically acceptable sense i think
there's certainly
very com
positive evidence that both exercise and
mental activity can make a difference
whether one type of activity versus a
different
is superior
i don't think there's enough
head-to-head evidence to say i recommend
meditation as compared to some other
kind of
playing a card game or doing it
working or doing any other kind of
activity so that's not been tested in
the same kind of rigorous way i know
that but i think you know being active
both mentally and physically is
unquestionably beneficial and strongly
to be encouraged absolutely using the
brain function will help
slow down perhaps the process of of
alzheimer's or dementia you've seen
studies regarding that
i think that certainly would be the
recommendation um exactly how much it
slows down and
how far we can go with that
we can't say today
still have to learn more about it
okay
dr chang
this person says uh is asking sure tell
telomere causes aging or cancers how
about increasing its length by
technology
the lengths of
should be home i just want to make sure
i that the length of
telomeres should be the same length in
all cells
should they be the same length in all
cells
i'm not sure what technology uh
the writer is referring to but the only
way to increase teal middle length that
i know of is through
the addition of telomerase
so if you add telomerase to for example
stem cells
it will rescue
the shortest telomeres so the shortest
telomeres are the ones that cause the
cellular senescence premature aging
phenotypes but if you add telomerase
dashboard telomere it's elongated and it
no longer triggers the dna damage
response
so i think that's the only way that we
know right now to add telomere length
although there are certain studies that
are not
you know
i don't necessarily believe it as some
small molecules may augment telomerase
activity
i think that's that requires a lot of
clinical trials so the lengths of what
about the lines of the
telomere should they be all the same
length in all the cells it's only the
shortest telomeres that we worry about
so
studies have shown that one short
telomeres can actually initiate
the cellular senescent mechanism so you
don't have to have all your telomeres to
be elongated but you just have to rescue
that one short telomeres that could
trigger the dna damage response
simply said but difficult to do very
difficult yes
okay dr christakis
about social contagious phenomena do you
think me the media or propaganda have
significant
effect
introducing and inducing the effect
okay
in inducing the effect
i would make a distinction between
broadcast mechanisms and these types of
social contagions so oprah winfrey
obviously has much more power than i do
to affect what people do in this country
but she does that via broadcast
mechanisms oprah actually probably does
not have more power any more or less
power than i do to affect her personal
friends
so oprah probably has about as many real
friends as i do and when she recommends
a movie to them or a recipe she probably
has about as much if well maybe not a
recipe but about as much effect as i do
so it's the difference and and i'm often
asked this question in the setting of
obesity how can it be
that we are gaining weight even though
our ideals about appropriate bodies have
remained relatively constant
and and the answer to that question is
that um you are much more affected by
what your friends are doing than you are
affected by what abstract individuals
are doing it's the same thing that leads
uh prison guards to abuse prisoners they
have the ideal that um that we shouldn't
do this but when their peers are abusing
the prisoners they copy them and so this
is a widespread phenomenon in socialism
both are important the ideal and the
broadcast message are important but the
pure effects are so much more powerful
than the uh uh than the broadcast
mechanism very good
one for the entire panel at the time
okay this is for all of you
how do we increase the likelihood that
policies change as a result of lessons
learned from research
dr chang
i mean
i think i think uh i think i think um
there's a saying i was recently told
that uh has really stuck with me which
is that you cannot reason a man out of
an opinion he hasn't been reasoned into
and i think that the quality of our
public discourse about science has
declined
and i think it's very difficult to use
reason to persuade people that the kinds
of uh that policy should be based on
rational uh grounds
so um
and and actually many would argue that's
not necessarily necessary i mean some
people would say
what makes you think that evidence
should be the
guide to policy you know maybe the guide
to policy should be some you know
god-given ideals for example or some
abstract principles the truth of course
is both because if you set policy
without evidence eventually you hit
reality and the policy doesn't work
um but that doesn't mean principles are
unimportant and i think there was a time
in our society i mean even i can
remember it i'm not that old where we
had a more um
a greater respect for the meaning of
evidence in um in formulating policy and
how to increase that i don't know maybe
one of my peers here has some ideas
anybody else i guess i would maybe
distinguish between
lessons learned and incorporated by
policy makers or incorporated by society
at large i think there's a huge benefit
towards
society at large recognizing more about
the science and the medicine of aspects
of aging
the more that the general population
knows about things that happen as
discussed in this kind of symposium or
other forums
i think the more public policy
political opinion
will
be somewhat more informed i i believe
i'm not going to give that up in a
institution of uh
higher learning that the more we can
spread knowledge the more
informed society will be and the more
lessons will translate into policy maybe
that's overly hopeful but i have to
believe that anyway i'm with you
well we've seen the impact of
people getting behind the research for
breast cancer
because it is such an emotional
issue for families and for women
funding has increased because of this
and because funding has increased
research
has moved everything forward for
women and so perhaps with the aging
issue that if we
arm people with more information that
they'll get behind this as more of us
live longer
especially when it comes to alzheimer's
we're saying one case comes up every
seven seconds that should be something
that we should all be concerned about
well i think there's growing concern
awareness of
frequently reported you know on the
front pages of newspapers
it's gaining more awareness i think what
what may not have reached the general
public is the idea that
science may be the solution to the
problems that we're all kind of
beginning to recognize more and more
that the aging population and
alzheimer's disease are
a growing problem a massive problem
what's our way out of it maybe science
is the way out of it maybe the nia
maybe
finding out more and discovering more is
our only solution but we need more money
though to do that
right well i think that i mean we also
need wisdom and good experiments and
and wise use of
the funding exactly a money problem but
of course that matters
absolutely anybody else would like to
jump in on that
i think just um you know i think your
question about this the uh aging people
people recognize it is the most uh
important health condition in this
country
people rally emotionally around
individual diseases
such as breast cancer it's a very good
example in fact we had grand rounds this
morning showing that
the potential downside consequences of
it being emotionally driven approach
that that if anything in in breast
cancer research is very very important
but it's um the the proportion of of
resources that go into breast cancer
really are out of proportion somewhat
too to and some not necessarily at the
expense because it's not a zero-sum game
but um
there are certain conditions that are
easier to rally emotions around and i
think a lot of this is emotion driven
and um
and and certainly those of us in aging
have really tried to do exactly what
you've talked about is trying to get
people to be aware and to focus and put
some resources into understanding um
aging is in it has been complex i mean
we've a lot of good minds have tried to
do and i think it's an important thing
but it it has i think we we haven't yet
gotten there in terms of how to resonate
resonated the way we should
dr tinetti this question is for you
my mother is on 12 different medications
can i do anything now
to help what can we do for her
well i think the um
that the most important thing is to have
a good discussion
with the doctor and unfortunately if
she's on 12 medicine she probably has
five or six doctors as well but the most
important thing is to find out from her
mother what's most important to her and
then to talk to her doctor and saying
this is what's important to my mother
which of these medications are most
likely to help and are any of them
hurting for what's most important to her
and that's that's really as good as we
can do right now because we really don't
have the research and the evidence to
say for each individual person this is
definitely what's right for you this is
definitely what's right for you but i
think at least we can start that
dialogue of at least heightening
everybody's awareness of of this
medication is it going to influence the
outcome that's most important to me and
that's the dialogue that we should be
having increasingly with our physicians
so the person who has his mother needs
to
talk to all her physicians perhaps
because the mom may not
be able to do so right or or even more
importantly what we advocate is is that
um this person and her mother identify
who is who should be the primary um
physician making the decision and and
really
and make it clear to the network of
physicians um to to uh use dr
work is that there is a network of
physicians is really identify one of
them who is the decision maker and
really feed all and rather than seven
doctors making uh making uh suggestions
is they all should make the suggestion
to the one doctor who weighs all of it
that's that's the ideal world it's not
the way medicine practices um but it's
it's it's the direction we're trying to
move and we're talking about
patient-centered care here it's
patient-centered care we all agree on it
who can disagree with it right it's like
apple pie but how do you make it happen
okay
dr christakis
can your network anal analysis
distinguish benefits of connections
between
ages
you mean intergeneration it says
generation i'll go on here it says
evolution tells us
often reproduction we
correct
we are no longer useful we we are no
longer useful but many of us appreciate
the wisdom of our elders i see
um actually
we i have just two two things to say
about that first is a very trivial
observation that uh humans
evince homophily on age that is to say
young people hang out with young people
and older people with older people and
this is like anything else that humans
do so there is age segregation within
these social fabrics that's not too
surprising and there's another body of
work which is not our work other people
have done work on the benefits of
grandparents uh in fact one of the
theories as to why um
why we lived so long evolutionary
biologists are taking this increasingly
seriously is that actually the ex the uh
your our survival after we reproduce and
our own children reach adulthood beyond
that
uh is precisely because it confers
fitness advantages to the next
generation and this you know in in
modern setting this could be include
everything from wealth transmission to
wisdom transmission and so forth and
actually you see this in elephants too
which is very interesting elderly
elephants herds that are led by older
elephants fare much better in times of
drought than herds that are uh
led by younger matriarchs so there's a
lot of convergent evolution evidence
from evolutionary biology uh that helps
shed light on why what the role of aged
individuals within the population is and
helps to explain why there's some
particularly long-lived species where
it's hard on first principles to
understand why what would be the benefit
to living to be 70.
incidentally even even
either
the survival was much shorter in bygone
era but that was primarily due to infant
mortality conditional and surviving to
five years we have lengthened survival
in humans over the last hundred years
but not as much as as you would think
and we have one last question is that
right okay and this will be the dr chang
no
okay well let me ask dr chang this
question really
dr chang the the telomere studies you've
conducted been in animal studies when
will it
go to the human side
i think that's the million-dollar
question with more support from the nia
i think
i think the first
telomerase therapy will probably be
conducted on patients with this
characteristic congenital patients with
a clear need
for telomerase
addition
and
you know
trials on on cells now have shown that
if you add telomerase to patients with
uh
cells or patients with discouraged
congenita it restores telomere length so
it's possible that these stem cells
could be transfused back to these
patients and you know they may be cured
of this potential disease now hopefully
in the future we could maybe use
telomerase therapy to engineer stem
cells to perhaps in terms of
regenerative medicine
to maybe make artificial organs and
things like that that we could
you know replace
aging organs in that particular fashion
maybe that would circumvent the
you know this cancer problem that's
always this
you know this flip side of this this do
you see clinical trials starting soon
human clinical trials
there have been
so there are trials against telomerase
so this anti-telomous therapy have been
in clinical drugs and these are
anti-cancer type of therapy using
specific oligonucleotides against
telomerase
and some of these clinical trials have
failed because they have been proven to
be too toxic
obviously patients stem cells have been
compromised
so as to whether you could restore
telomerase
in as an anti-aging therapeutic that has
not been
attempted yet
very good all right so our last question
is a very optimistic i just have to say
these questions reflect the level of
optimism that's phenomenal
could you say
more about how you identify
a central per person for intervention
targeting
so i i use the centrality of the
individuals as an illustration it
actually turns out that you wouldn't
necessarily want to use central people
but it's a very visually easy concept to
to show and actually our algorithms
don't necessarily emphasize central
people but it is mathematically not
difficult to identify central people and
uh and uh
basically
central people are people whose friends
are more central and that that may sound
like the tale you know the snake eating
its own tail but actually you can work
out that math and you can find
individuals who are not only uh who are
not only have many friends but whose
friends have many friends and that's in
a sense one of the definitions of
centrality the other definition is is
that central people are on more paths
through the network
of all the paths you could define and
you can define all the paths there's a
finite set through any network a central
person will have more of those paths go
through them so you can use this math to
identify them very good
thank you very much and thank you for
being here they did a terrific job
didn't they
and again you are all welcome to join
the reception immediately following